You
Hey posers
Are there really real goffs here?
Any goffs in the house
Any goffs yeah, it's me
It's me. It's shibbany. Yeah
Take it over my my aunt's channel
Yeah
Yeah, my aunt shibby
I'm shibbany. I you might have not met me. I haven't been around in a bit, but I'm a true goff. Okay, I'm
I'm goffic
Thanks for watching
Get it cuz I'm goff
So anyways
Today we're gonna be finishing
My
immortal
Also, don't worry about my head
Popping off my body. Just don't it just ignore that. Okay. It's a little bit odd
You don't have to worry about it
I
My aunt borrowed my hoodie, I don't know how she fits in my clothes
Cuz like I don't have a lot of booba, but she uses like
She has a lot
You listen to Pierce the veil. Mmm
Maybe
maybe
Yeah, you guys know I'm a dollahan as a lot are in my family
Alright, so I was gonna well she be was gonna play
Hitman absolution as planned just a little bit later after she got out over her headache
But none of her controllers are working. So I'm taking over. This is my stream now
My chemical romance my chemical romance. Yeah
Breaking Benjamin three days grace
Three days grace
Maybe I'll think about it
Yeah, Agent 47 is a prep. So it doesn't even matter. I
Heard you guys hung out with my sister too. So that's pretty neat. I
Ignore my dogs in the background
That is gold mask
Yeah, I have a dog named gold mask. Hold on. Let me find a good spot
Let's see
Does this work?
So you guys can see what's happening that do you two broke like raid messages and gaming stuff
The I mean the chat. I don't know why I said gaming stuff
It's kind of you know stupid
All right, we might not be able to see you what do I use this one I use this challenge it
I don't even know where it is
I
Looks like you guys just don't matter what you have to say it's cuz you're all preps
Preps stop flaming me
You guys can't see but I'm putting up devil horns. Hold on
Let me let me let me put up some devil horns
Oh
Cuz we're Satan worshipers in this household
Yeah rock on
You ready
Are you ready? This is this definitely looks like it's attached to me, right?
He'll say and I guess indeed indeed
All right. Hi. Hi. Welcome in if you don't know who I am. I've seen me got some new faces
I see that I think feel alert. Oh, I just smack the mic punch the mic punch my feel there as a whole has been growing some
So let me introduce myself or I'll introduce my aunt
My aunt is she be caught in bomb. She is a very talented
Talented lady. She is a dominatrix bunny
I don't even know what that means and she likes to voice act and she likes to
Be silly and dress up. I don't really know what that means. I hope she doesn't dress as prep. Um,
Yeah, and she she's pretty neat, I guess like she's my cool aunt I've been on that's a nun
She's not so cool. She like kind of hates me. So it's whatever
Yeah, from veiler generation one indulge exactly
But uh, my aunt will probably be around tomorrow because I think she has like a collab
I hope it's not with the prep. Let me pull up the website and let me get rid of this
stupid stuff
Because chat doesn't work. Oh wait, you know what I can do
We just pop out the chat. How about that?
Oh my god, if my dog gold mask could stop acting up right now
Gold mask cut it out. Jesus
Nope, that's not it. Don't worry about it. Hold on
Where the heck is
It's not working
Oh my god, I'm literally gonna freaking
The explode
OBS is being a real prep right now guys
Gold mask is pretty noisy. I hope his name would help but it didn't
There we go, I don't know why this one is a freaking working
Okay
Baba the boopy
I'll have to do a bunch of window captures actually. I'll just save that right there for now
Yepy, can you tell that? I definitely
surprise what
What's wrong with you? Why would I just have that in my tabs, bro? Are you kidding me?
What's wrong with you home slice?
Get rid of that let's get rid of that. Oh my god, it's you guys. Oh
My god, it's you
Uh, hold on please hold there we go
Oh, let me make myself a little bit smaller
There you go. Look my pinky is over there
Oh from freaking moving everything except what I want to move there you go. All right
We move this let me pull up the thing. Yeah, they're scuff
Yeah, because I was I was gonna do
Hitman absolution I set up for that. I made myself bald
I'll show you
But now I can't do that now I can't I now I it's not working
Hitman absolution is not working
So we're just gonna
We're just gonna do this. All right. We're just doing this so mind the scuff. I am also having eaten
So I'm eating a bowl of cereal
Mm-hmm
That's some good cereal
Um
I don't even remember what chapter we were on
Quick somebody go look at my past fan fiction thing
Watch I have a cereal am I eating? Uh, I'm eating
Uh
Post it honey o's because those are my favorite
I've never met anybody else that eats them. I guess I'm just weird
I'm not like the other girls. I'm quirky and I eat weird cereal
Looks like chapter 30. I think you're right. I think it is chapter 30
Uh
fanfic
Is it this one?
I found it
Boomi I mean gold mask stop it
Gold mask quit acting out
Stop chasing renola
Queen of the moon
I
Slurp
Yeah, you're so much different from other girls. That's what I'm saying, dude. I'm not like them
I'm like
I don't know man. I don't know why I sound like I sound a real tomboy right now
Oh my god
My dogs are jumping everywhere
I
Perfect
Ignore this random dude in the corner. I'm gonna cover his face. We don't need to look at Eric whoever the frick Eric is
He's probably a poser
He's probably not a real one
Sure that works
Let me cover this dude's face ram renola stop
Oh my god, gold mask is making weird noises
Is this what I want? I'm scared. I'm scared if I click image what it's gonna show up. Oh, that's not right
Any Eric's in the chat. Oh, let me find
Yes, we're removing image
Add image new image
Let's go
Uh
What
Please hold I swear I'm entertaining
Oh perfect, let's use my this looks really awkward
Yeah, sorry Eric you gotta go
This noise it sounds especially like a cat. I don't know what to tell you. I just have a really weird dog
Um
Anyways
So, uh, let's start this party shall we I don't know why I sound like a surfer
I forget which I think I I'll remember I'll remember my own voice
As we go along. Let me put my milk away
You're just on time edited by
That's the that's the noise when you see that email
I also have like some beef jerky to eat so I can eat some beef jerky with my cereal
Oh my god, I'm being chased by my dogs
Um
My dogs are harassing me for treats bro
Although their food dispenser is gonna go off at like nine
Beef jerky and cereal is a banger meal. Yeah, I told you I'm not like other girls
Stop hissing dogs. Don't hiss. It's not what dogs do
Um, what the heck am I doing who am I
There we go can make this bigger sick. All right. I'm on chapter what 30
Ignore her face ignore this lady's face
I mean
What is happening here? Oh, that's fine actually
Nope
Chapter 31 got it
You
You guys are too big get get smaller get smaller eyes
Sorry Janice type of fucking name is Janice. It's a prep name
Anyways, we have a piece of beef jerky
Oh, I should probably sleep. Oh frick. Hold on
Um
I want to sleep
Pop's never gonna sound like a
Hey now you're an all-star. Okay, get your game on go play
This is gonna be turkey it's sweet and spicy beef jerky
I
Let me retweet this nice
All right, we're finishing this
What is going on what the fuck is going on I want some water next to me
You ready you ready to get sloshed
Sorry I became a bit of a dude bro, but I'll become myself as I start reading
All right, all right, all right
If you haven't seen
What's happened in the past, I'm sorry, you're missing out on kino content. Okay
top tier
content
Uh, so you will probably have to go back and listen to my other videos
Or not, you can just hang out with me right now. That's totally fine. Don't leave me
I didn't say you could leave
The bell doesn't dismiss you I do okay
I'm rubbing my hands together like a little fly
Um
Yeah, leave a like and comment if you like what you've seen so far
You should totally
Like comment and subscribe
And jorke that bell
Mm-hmm jorke it like the peanuts it has
Uh
Tdlr, uh, we're a girl named ebony darkness dementia way
I wrote this fanfiction by the way. You guys didn't know that I wrote it. Uh, it's about it's a self-insert about me
Uh
And uh, so I'm in a love triangle with harry potter who's known as vampire
In uh drake a malphoy. We love listening to good charlotte and um my chemical romance
Uh, Voldemort's trying to get me to kill drako. Everybody's goth by the way. They're all goths in emo. Um
This this has sensitive
How do you not know what tdlr means?
Oh, oh
Let me um
Rlt dt
Let me put
Let me let me my head's falling out of my hoodie. Oh frick man
Hold on it's gonna bother me
Let me just put my throw that away. Let me make this a little bit bigger
Hold on. Don't worry about it. Don't worry that I have to eat. Don't look
Don't ask why there's a ring there
Yes, I use
Don't worry about it
Stop looking my neck is super
Uh, you know what oh pitchfork
I'ma stab you
Wait
Put the hood back on. All right
Now we're in show business
Why her neck on weird? Why your face on weird?
You ugly
Get some help
Your face whack
Your shoes whack your fit whack
You know what?
I was gonna burp. It didn't really work out for me. Okay. Okay. Okay
Chapter 31
I always knew you on vozemore's side you son of a bitka
What
Sirius said to Snape
No, I'm not. I was teaching them something
Snap clammed
Oh fucking yeah, I took some black vulva mortis serum out to my pocket and gave it to severus
He made snap
Drunk it. He did angrily then luscious took out a tape recorder and started playing it while he did curses on snap
Then oh, yeah, I might not have the best grammar when I wrote this. Don't worry about it. Okay
All right, you guys you guys get that
I understood
Then professor sinister and lucian made us get out with him
Well, Snape told his sacratess
lucian took vampir and draco to the nurse after thanking me a million times
Professor trivlery took me to a dark room
Now I was going to go back in time to seduce volzemort
Moving posters of mcr and nirvana
Were all over her. My need darkness and willow came to
Bloody mary gave me a blank bag from tom reds store
What's in the bag I asked professor trivlery
You will see she said I hope but wait what voice I don't remember the voice as I gave people
Yeah, it's my immortal lock in strap in brother
Um
Open the bag the bag in it
Let's megan the bag in it was a sexy titay low smut black leather gothic dress
It had red corset stuff and there was a slit up the leg
I put it on
My friends helped me put on the black fitness and black pointy boots willow had chosen
Willow in darkness by the way, that's that's jenny weasley. Help me put on black eyeliner and blood red lipstick
You look fucking kawaii bitch bloody mary said
Thanks. I said
Okay, now you're wait. No, I gave her a scottish accent
I gave her a scottish accent. I've any valley girl draker drako domi mommy potter goofy dumbledore cowboy snape snape
Yes, the film this it's willow smith. No willow is my best friend. Uh self insert iral by the way
Uh, I gave her I gave her because I thought of sin sister. That's right
Okay, now you're going back in time in tim. Sorry, it's tim back in tim go back into tim
Said professor sinister
You will have to do it and you'll have to do it in a few sessions
She gave me a black gun. Hold on. I gotta get my gun out. Oh my god. I always
Let me get my gun
I fought the law in the law one
Let's go. All right, I got it
You
Know I stay strapped, bro. The gun is golf. Mm-hmm. It's a it's a Glock o'clock
There are guns there's guns in the harry potter worlds
Fuck fuck a wand. We we got guns. All right
Um
I
Put a strap on what
I put a
Yo, I didn't know was this about the fan fiction fan fiction
I put it in. Oh, I put it in a strap on my fishnets like in red red red disnet evil
Then she gave me a black time tuner
After an hour used a time turner to go back here
Professor travelry said
Then she and bloody mary put a pensive
what
In front of me
Everyone went in front of it
Good luck. Everybody shoot it
Darkness and willow gave me death's touch sim
sin
Then I jumped sexily into the pensive
Suddenly I was in ford to the school in front of me was one of the sexiest goth guys I had ever seen
He was wearing long black hair kind of like mikey way only black
He had red eyes like billy joe armstrong and pale whit skin
He was wearing a black ripped up suit with vans. It was
Tom Bombadil
Chapter 32
Hi
I said furly
I'm a nobie way the new student
I shocked my pale hands with the black male posh with him
The name's tom. He said but you can call me sight and that's my middle name
Nom
Sorry anyways, um, we shock hands
Well, come on. We have to go upstairs satan said I followed him
Hey, sit and do you happen to be a fan of grande?
Since mcr and evanescence don't exist yet then I asked
Oh
My fucking god, how did you know satan gasp actually I like gc a lot too
Get it cuz gc did that song. I just want to live that sounded really 80s
Oh and gee me too don't ask the schematics of us going back in time to win
Uh
Voldemort was a student. Yes. Good charlotte and mcr were still around
Voldemort's only like in his 20s. Okay when I wrote okay like you guys get this
I'm gonna have a piece of beef jerky
Guess what they have a concert in hogsman. Oh, sorry. Guess what I have a concert in hogsman satan whispered hogsman
What yeah, that's what they call it in these time before but how does he know that how does he know
Gold mask get off my desk
Gold mask I can't see past your your big body. Okay
Uh, yeah, that's what they call it in these time before it became hogsmeade in 2000
He told me all that sequitively and there's a really cool shop called hot
Topic I finished happy again. He frowned confusedly
No, it's called hot issue
He smiled secret scretilla v again
Then in 1998 they changed it to hot topic
Oh, he moaned
Hi, how does he
How does he know these things alone people I'm chewing beef jerky
Oh
Now everything was making sense for me
So as dumbling door your principal
I shouted
Uh-huh. He looked at his black nails. I'm in Slytherin
Um, jeez me too
I shook it in
You go to the skull
Get it because I'm gothic. He asked
Yeah, that's why I'm here. I'm no I smelled happily
He
Suddenly don't we door flew in on his broom stuck and started shredding on his angrily
No talking it. Wait. Oh, it's a cowboy accent, but okay gold mask you have to leave
Now talking into hot and what that's that's that's not that's the guy from kingsman
Uh
Yeehaw yeehaw yeehaw
Yeehaw no talk. No
And I'm just from the south and I'm just from the south no talking in the halls
He had short blonde hair and was wearing a polo shirt from american ogle outfitters stupid golfs
How does one smell happily stop asking questions you don't even know the answer to I pissed myself. Um
I
Come home after tequila shots with the home girls and I'm somehow not drunk enough for this
Oh, that's great. Thank you
Wait, if there's doughnose I can't see them
I'm gonna make this burger
I'm gonna put my headphones on
I do a text to speech turned on
BT dubs
Oh my god, I can hear myself
Hold on
Be quiet shut up me. We don't need to hear me gross disgusting. Anyways
You'll text and I'll text you your speech to turn on
That's what you sound like
Satan rolled his eyes
He's so mean to us golfs and punks just because we're in Slytherin and we're not preps
I turned around angrily. Actually, I think maybe it's because you're the bark lord
WTF he asked angrily. Oh nothing. I said sweetly
I
Then subtle in the floor ellipses ellipses ellipses the floor opened. Oh my fucking god. No
I screamed as I feel down
Everyone looked at me weirdly
Hey, where are you going?
Satan asked as I fell
I got out of the hole and it was back in the pensive in professor's traveller's classroom. Dumbly Dumb was there
Dumbly door. I think I just met you. I said
Howdy, howdy. Oh, yeah, I remember that Dumbly door said trying to be all gothic sinister came in
I can't keep track of the voices. Hey
Hey, hi, this is my cost room. Wait, what's a fucking obi? What the hell are you doing?
Um
I looked at her. Oh, yeah, I forgot about that
Wth how I screamed forgetting she was a teacher for a second, but she's a golf so it's okay
Professor sinister. I can't keep track of the story. Don't you don't have to
Professor sinister looks sad
Um, I was drinking Voldemort serum. She started to cry black tears of depression
Dumbly Dom didn't know about them
Hey, are you crying tears of blood he asked curiously touching a tear
Fuck off. We both said and Dumbly Dom took his hand away
Professor sinister started crying again in her chair sobbing limpid tears
Oh my fucking god, I know be I think I'm addicted to Voldemort serum
No
Chapter 33
Oh my fucking god, I should have sadly should we get you to st. Manga's bitch
Hell no, she said listen Egoge. I need your help next time you go back in time
Do you think you could ask Tom Anderson for some help?
Sure, I said sadly I went outside the door Draco was there
He was wearing a big black gct. Shit, which was his panamas
Hey sexy
How'd it go? No, he
He asked in his voice was so sexy and low con like Gerard way when he's talking
Fine a respondent. We started to go back to the dorm
How far did you go with Satan?
Draco asked jealously
Not too far. Oh well. I borked
Bork bork bork
Will you have to do it with him Draco asked angstily
I hope not too far. I shouted angrily. Then I felt bad for shooting it. Sorry
I hope not too far. I shouted angrily. Then I felt bad for shooting at him. I'm sorry. We french
What happened to snipe I growled
You will see
Draco giggled mysteriously
He opened a door snap and lumpkin was there serious was pokering them by stagging them with a black knife
I think drake on satan will kiss uh drake goes with me. So we better not
No, please
Lumpkin bagged as serious started to suck his blood. I laughed statistically
stat stat stat stat
I took some photons of him
And snap being torqued
Okay, I know this is men but think about it people
They are pedos and snap tried to wrap them in new a status rock has anyone see shrack attack three elves
We took some of snipe's blood then draco and I went back to our rooms
We sat on my gothic black coffin
My clothes were kind of dirty. So I popped on a black leather outfit thingy kind of like one saline has in underworld
If you haven't heard of it, then fuck yo
I put on some black platform high heels
Darko put on
Desolation livers by mcr
Then we started to take off the cluthrothers closest
Wait, why did I put on clothes just to have him take them up? Don't worry about it
I talked off his shit and he had a six pack lulls
We started to make out like in the grudge
He pot his wetness in my you know what sexily I've got an orgy
Oh, draco 11111 exclamation point one. Oh my fucking good draco exclamation point 111
I screamed passively as he got an arook station
I love you to ebery
He whispered sexily and then we fell asleep. Oh
Yeah, I don't know. I don't remember what a rock citation means
chapter 34
Oh, yeah, I don't really bother with the author's notes because
It's fine
We're here for the the story. I already know what I wrote in the author's notes
I woke up into coffin the next day draco was gone
I got up and put on a black tight sex address that was ripped up at the end
There was a red corset stuff going up the fort into black and it came up to my it's my music too loud
Um
To my knees there was a slit in the dress like in licking mr. Mrs. Smith
Mr. And mr. Smith, excuse me. We're progressive. I put on a wrap ripped black fishnets and black stilton boots
Suddenly sorious cocked on the door. I opened it
Hi ebony
He said guess what I have to come to professor sinister's office
Okay, I said a depraised voice
I'd want it to fuck draco and maybe listen to mcr evanescence. I came anyway
So what the fuck happened to sniping lupin?
I asked sirius flirtally
I fucking tortured them. He answered in a statistic way stats stats stats. They are an abca abca hazi and now
Hello, well, I laughed easily
Where are draco and vampira I muttered
They are excused from school today. Sodomize mone
Sorry, hold on. Let me rewrite that reread that
Damn excuse from school today. Oh
Sodomize mone sexily. All right. Now. They are watching the nightmare before wait. Sorry. That's a different voice right now
They're watching the nightmare before christmas xmas
Um
We went into the office professor sinister was there. She was wearing a gothic black
Dress that was ripped up all over kind of like the one amy lee wears in this pic
What picture I want to see the picture it doesn't show
She was drinking some volzumort serum
She took up defensive into time torner
And obi you'll have to do another session now
Also, I need you to get me to cure before being addicted. She said sadly. Good luck fangs
And then I jumped into the pensive again
Prince of pence. I don't know what that says suddenly. I looked around
I was in the great hall eating count. Chorcula. It was morning
I was sitting next to satan
On the table was a tall gothic man with long black hair pale skin and blue eyes wearing a suit and black
converse shoes
He looked just like charlin manson
It's a cross between charlie manson and maryland manson
I noticed he was drinking a portent
Who's he I asked? Oh, that's professor slut born. What is that his name?
Is there a character in harry potter named slut born?
Is that an actual character slughorn, okay
Satan said he's the portents teacher ellipses ellipses ellipses ebony
Yeah, I asked
Did you know that maryland manson is playing in hogsmeade tonight? I thought it was hogsment
And they are sewing the exercise at the movies before that. Yeah
Well, what to go to the contort and a movie with me
Oh my god, you can't see but i'm fanning myself
They did a dirty. Hello. Hi chapter 35
I went into the common room thinking of satan suddenly. I gasped traco was there
wait
Oh, sorry, I read ahead a little bit. That was quite the twist. I grasped he looked as hot as eva where hot as eva
I'm satan they rush and wearing a black letter pants a black lunken crack t-shirt and black eyeliner
Traco, what the fuck are you dong? I go go sped
Huh, he then he asked then I remembered it wasn't draco. It was luke luke hand. He's still at two arms
Oh, by the way, uh, lucian in previous chapters got his arms blown off
Or one of them. I can't remember
I see what you come from
Hi, everybody. It's your favorite us ice polar bear princess. I say snow paws. Yes drink my yellow snow
um
Oh, hi lucian. I said i'm ebony the new student. Oh, well, we shook hands. I said this all because it's all in
quotations
Yeah, yeah, I see his voice is my favorite to do
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, I sense on me about you
Should that be lucian's voice
I
Don't even know what that voice was. It was like britney spears
Get it get it get it get it
I shrieked it into that voice. Okay. Okay
He pinted to a group of sexy gothic guys. They were sitting in a corner cutting
Oh
Um, it was serious. Yes, that is a serious thing vampires dad and snap
All of them are wearing black eyeliner and black good char lute by and shirts
Listen, I'm in a goth band with those guys. He said we're playing tonight at the Marilyn Manchin show was black up
Orly I sked
Yeah, he said
We're called x black x tear x
I play the good the gutter
Spartacus plays
Spartacus plays the drums
He said pointing to him
snap plays the boss and james plays the guitar too even though we call him samra
At this samra in the ring
Hey bastards
I told them they gave me the death touch sin suddenly I gasped again
But don't you have a lead singer? I guess lucian looked dawn sadly
We used to but she did she attempted suicide by slitting her wrists
Oh my fucking god, that's so fucking sad. I gasped
What is that word?
Okay
That isn't it's in it's in the dictionary
That is a word
All right, everyone
I'm waiting for someone to like so this is what's gonna happen
Someone's gonna clip me saying this
and then
What I want you to do
Is to after I say it I need you to make an edit of the cyberpunk music
And then just with the word. Okay, and then be like
You know how it goes. All right
Let me reread this
Oh my fucking god one one that's so fucking sad
I gasped
It's okay, but we need a new lead snigger
Samaro said
Well, I said
I'm gonna banad myself
Really
Wait, really a snap. I couldn't believe it. He used to be gothic
Like the silver hand edits. Yes
Yeah, we were called we're called the bloody gothic rose 666. Do you want to hear me sing?
Yeah, said everyone so the guys talk out their guitars
They began to play a song by get it because by guys are so sexy
Gern day
I walked this empty street on the boulevard of broken drums
I sang sexually
I did not own the lyrics to that song everyone gasped
I need a burp
Why is there
And no be will you join the band please beg lucy and samoro serious and snap?
Um, okay
I shrugged are we gonna almost threw up are we gonna play tonight? Are we gonna play tonight?
Yeah, they said
Okay, I said, but I knew that I had to get a new outfit. I walked outside wondering how I could go forward in time
Suddenly someone jumped in front of me. It was morty mcflough
Morty
He was wearing a black bonad t-shirt and black bonaggy jeans. What the hell are you doing here? I asked
I will help you go forward until I can I can't do his voice. What am I supposed to do there?
out of teen wolf
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do a really like
ash catch of voice
I will let me go forward in time a newbie
He said seriously then he booked out a black time tim machine. I went into it and suddenly I was forwarding tim
Chapter 36
Let's make your voice sticky
No guys
You guys are foul
Oh
I have a piece of beef jerky
Why are you and tim? Why aren't you and tim?
And tim has that delicious bussy. Okay. I don't know what to tell you
What's in black we can't just ask people why they're black
I
Why are you white? I'm assuming
Uh sorry drink of water
I
Wish there would be a guy that just like just shows up and his name is tim and he's just like hey guys
like in the chat
Chapter 36
I locked around in the pressed way suddenly. I saw professor sinister bloody mary socrates
Socrates
Always supposed to be serious black
And draco vampire and willow so uh bloody mary. So this is uh sinister trollani
Uh, this is bloody mary smith serious black draco harry potter and my friend willow
We're there too
Oh my fucking god, sorry as I saw you in samaro and snip and everyone I can't believe snap used to be gothic
Yeah, I know serious said sadly
Oh, hi there, bitch. Oh, hey there, bitch
professor trevoree said in an email was a
Oh, hi there, bitch professor trevoree said in emo boys
Drinking some volzomorcelum
Uh hi fucker. I said listen see and asked me out to a gothic concert in a movie
So I need a sexy new outfit for the date
Also, I'm playing in a gothic band. So I need an outfit for that too
Oh my sights and
Get it lolz cuz she's gothic
Oh, it's right. Oh my satan
Gas bloody mary want to go to hot topic and shop for your outfit
Oh
Mms. Oh mfs. Let's have a group cut in session said professory trevoree
I can't fucking wait for that, but first we need to get some stuff first said willow
Yeah, we need some portions for professory trevoree, so she won't be addicted to volzomorcelum. Who's talking? Oh
Yeah, we need some portions for professory trevoree, so she wouldn't be addicted to volzomorcelum anymore and
also
Some love potion for a nobie
Darko said resultantly
Sorry, uh rinala and gold masker chasing each other around my house right now
What is mc kind of no she doesn't
Um
well
We have potions class now
Willow said so let's go
We went sexily. You can't see but i'm jiggling my chest to potions class, but snap wasn't there and said there was
Cornelio fuck
Hey, where the fuck wait, sorry. Hey, where the fuck is dumbly door drago shout angrily
Shut the fuck up. She did cornelio fuck. He's an uskaba as as kahabian now with snip and lupin
He is old and weak and he has cancer now. Do your work
My friends and I talked angrily
Can you believe snap used to be gothic i mean a prayer asked surprisingly
That's it cornelio fuck. Shooted angrily. I'm getting professor bridge
he stopped
out angrily
My friends and I began talking again. I began to drink some blood mix wicks with some beer. Suddenly I saw hargurud in the cupboard
What the fuck is he doing?
Then I looked at drago. He was wearing tons of eyeliner and he looked sexier than ever
suddenly
Hargraf what the fuck are you doing? Wait hargraf what the fuck are you doing? He's shooting
I looked around hargurud was putting something in my glass of blood
Was he trying to roofie me? Darko and vampire started to beat him up sexily
God you are such a poser
I shooted at hargurud hargurud suddenly I looked at what he was putting into blood. It was amnesia portion
My cat food dispenser is going off. I mean my dog food dispenser
How do you beat someone sexily? I don't know just look hot
Something you can't relate to oh burn get fucking wrecked bro. Oh my god suck my quit. I mean what?
Oh
YouTube youtube i'm on youtube. I forget that i'm on youtube. Um
I'm sorry
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Please forgive me
Please
Oh guys, you want to hear something funny?
I have a very funny idea for my next asmr
Do you want to hear it do you want to hear my funny story? I mean my funny funny idea
You find me on the street and i'm homeless
And I just beg I beg on the street and asmr
Everything good with you landlord my landlord. What about my landlord?
No, no, oh, yeah, no my I'm fine, but it'd be funny. Hold on. Let me feed my other cat
uh
um uh
millennia
Oh sweet
Oh here millennia
Millennia's barking don't worry about that
No, I'm just ensuring miladia uses the bathroom
Beggar asmr
Hold on let me get her some food
The bathroom
My cat millennia is inflicted with scarlet rot. So I mean my dog. Um, so I have to help her with
Uh eating and using the facilities
Jesus special dog
Don't ask why my dog meows
I
She's bilingual exactly
Wait is mr. Beverly gonna kick you out of her house
Uh, no, this will be it'll be a new it'll be a new family member the homeless one
And it they'll sound like all of her choice
Please please may I have some more?
Oh
I mean millennia's food
Millennia's special
Water
Hi, ronaldo, how can I help you ronaldo your food is the bowl
Rinaldo you better eat or gold mask is gonna eat it all
I
Oh
Are you pissing?
No, you have a pee do it
I'm cooking exactly I'm cooking
I always be cooking I'm in the kitchen
In the kitchen was twisted like a stir fry
What's up ronaldo?
Distant shibbety my lovin
Sorry I'm cleaning a food dish
Are you not entertained?
That I'm in the distance doing my dishes so I can feed my pet
I didn't expect to be streaming this late so
And a kid a dog he's got to eat you know
I
Got a pee
Me a favorite towel I just spilled water everywhere
And gold mask keeps harassing me there's food in your bowl
Gold mask
All right, what do you what do you prep saying?
You like the water noise
Nobody's asking you gold mask
What do you look like that
We're making that face
What are you doing?
Hi
Don't worry
Where did the food go?
I got you some special food just for you missy
Now gold mask don't you eat it or I'm gonna fight
Gold mask leave it alone
You know what bring it over here so I can keep it on
gold mask
stop
Literally you have your own food you just want it because it's a different bowl
Okay
Lani are you ready?
Can you eat that food all?
Go away go away. I'm gonna take out the squirt bottle if you guys keep eating it. Oh my god
God
Are you asking me to baby you don't have the bottle page you don't need
You've been she's been eating uh
She's been eating kibble
But I think she's
Being particular she likes to eat it from my hand
I like to eat it from a bowl for whatever reason
Oh
What
I'm a small water
Come on
I
She'd be trying to feed her cat ASMR
Eating kibble like a prep
Yeah, she's she's recovering from her prep boomy
I haven't gone it's a squirt bottle ladies and gentlemen. I'm not gonna
Yeah, come on. Are you not hungry?
She like you're not hungry. I think you just want to go back to sleep. Let me go put you away then
Um, she's only squeaking because I'm picking her up. By the way, she's not in any pain if you hear her meow. She's fine
Want to say hi
No, no you stop me. I'll be okay
You
And I'll try again feeding you after the stream
Seems like you just want the rest boomy
Get gone
Okay
Don't go out on me
I thought I had a cat about a horse
Thank you for uh being so patient as I uh take care of my family. I am a single mother raising three cats
I mean three dogs
I
Okay, hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick. It'll be like two seconds
You
There's water everywhere. No, it's not my pee. It's from the water bowl that I spilled
Oh
Slipped on a comically sized cheese slice what?
What's happening? Why did I just come back to
You
How is there I didn't even know there was just a loading emoji. Where did that come from?
Or is that just an email all right
Stream buffered badly for a moment. That's that's finally so it was I was gone when I was mostly gone
I'm just cleaning up a puddle
Oh fuck is that
Thought it was a bug it's not okay
Wow
Okay, I'm gonna need to stop
Draco time I can't believe she bit the shotgun
Chapter 37
This is an important author's note. Um, my immortal was never finished
Because I because I went on vacation
Okay, everybody. I'm going on vocation the 1st of july so I'm either gonna end the fic or update it in a week
Things. Oh, yeah, and preps up flaming. So story ramming. Thanks for to help see a girl after vocation
While a baby
Well, why aren't you making nintendo noises? Why aren't you huh? Why aren't you making nintendo noises?
I was trying to think of something funny to say and I couldn't so I'll just say your name and I'm getting
Because you're funny funny look
Get dunked on
Darko's point of view lol
Vampire and I chained. Yeah. Yeah, you thought you're gonna bully me chat. No
I just bully you
That's why I have a gun out. I have a gun
Pointed at your head right now in minecraft, of course
And it's pressed against your skull
I'm really pointing out my arm towards my wall
Towards my phone
And I'm laughing at you
Darko's point of view lol
Vampire and I chained. Hargret to the floor
Oh my fucking statement and obi said she was so hot
Maybe I could use amnesia potion to make satan fall in love with me faster
But you're so sexy and wonderful anyway tata said vampire. Why would you need it?
To make everything go faster lol
But you won't have to do
But you won't have to oh my god. I can't read
But you won't have to do it with him or anything. Will you?
Hmm. I asked I asked jealously
Oh my fucking oh my fucking god you guys are so scary
Said britney your fucking prep
Shut the fuck up said willow
Okay, well anyway, let's go to professor travelry's room
I'm back. What did I miss? Yes
Don't feed me cause she shot cold mask
Draco ebony and I went to professor senators room, but professor sinister wasn't there
Instead tom red was
Oi hi fuckers. He said listen. I got some cool new clothes
I took out the clothes from the bag. It was a golf
I was trying to do like butchers boys
Black leather miniskirt that sits six six six on the back black slit on boots black red fishnets and a black corset
Wait, did this switch back to
My
Does this switch back to the add to an nob's ebony's point of view? I'm so confused
Oh, I am. Oh, yo, yo, yo, I am bully but your old lambda took my son
Okay
Girls need to take a character that'd be so fun. I would love to do that
um
I think that'd be a really fun, uh
A collab
Somebody submit ideas to to to straw me for for that
um
I took out the clothes from the bag
It was gothic black leather miniskirt that said six six six on the back black slit on boots blood red fishnets in the black corset
OMG thing
I said hugging him in a gothic way
I don't know what that means. I took the clothes in the bag
Okay
Okay, professor sinister isn't here. What the fuck should we do as strako?
Suddenly he looked on at a sign on the black wall
Oh my fucking statement
I screamed as I read it on it said everyone professor sinister is away
She's too gothic. She isn't as caban as cabian now
Classes shall be taught by double dork who is back, but he shall not be principal for now
Sincerely sincerely professor rumbridge
Oh my fucking god. I shot it angrily hold on
Wow, wow
I make myself laugh
um
How could they do that?
suddenly Dumbly door came
What the hell you doing in my office? He began to shoot angrily
Sud suddenly I saw morty mcfly's black tim machine
I jumped seductively
Into it leaving drake going vampire. It sucks for them. Suddenly. I was back in tim. Oh my god. We're in tim again
I looked around it was
Professor slut borne's efface. I sneaked around suddenly. I saw it at amnesia potion on his desk
It was black with blood red pentagrams in it
It was the same shape of a cross. I put it in my pocket my pocket
Suddenly the door opened it was professor slut borne
I'm trying to think of a
Hold on land to do that. I'm trying to think of a voice for professor slut borne
Oh
My god, what are you doing fucker?
He's shooting angrily. I don't know what the fuck are you doing? I shoot it angrily
What
Oh, sorry, I was just looking around because I thought it was class
You finally said hoping he wouldn't see the potion in your pocket
You me
Me I said that
Yes, I did like me dragon stalling. Thank you
Oh, okay, you can go now. I don't even know the voice you just did. I don't care anymore
You went to the common room. We change we're changing
We're changing
What person we're in
After putting on my clothes
Silas
Samuro and snap where they're practicing vampires will never hurt you by mcr
Oh, hi you guys. I said seductively. Where's Satan?
Oh, he's coming. It's a serious. By the way, you can call me Hades now
suddenly Hades
the game
Hades mentioned
Suddenly satan came. Oh, he was wearing a smexy black leather jackson
Black congress suit is one of the jackson fly five a slipknot t-shirt in a black tie
Okay, I will see you guys at the concert. I said and then I went with satan
Can I go to the next chapter, please? Okay
Sergius's dad
Spear on me you changing clothes gold mask. What are you doing?
Gold mask up attack over Nala
She doesn't want to play with you gold mask
He doesn't want to join the golden order leave her alone
She's carrion
She's carrion queen
Sit and I walked to his car. It was a black car with pentagrams all over it
On the license plate said 666 just lick jackos car. I went in seductively
Stan who stan
K I left my name my number and my address at the bottom. You still ain't called. Sorry
Uh started to drive it. We talked about satanism lol because he was named after satan cutting music and being gothic
Oh my satan Gerard is so fucking hot
Volsley more agreed as we smoked some weed
Cause by guys are hot. They are so sensitive. I love them lol ghost fucks a by guy
What
Oh, well, I totally decided not to commit suicide when I heard Helena
I said hold on let me reread that
LL I totally decided not to commit suicide when I heard Helena
I said in a flirty voice. Hey satan. Do you know the cure for when people are addicted to volzmer serum?
Well, he thought I think you have to drink vampire blood
Suddenly volzmer parked a car behind a black movie theater satan. Who why is volzmer and satan here?
granola, what's happening?
but
Dude leave her alone
don't make me
I don't know if you heard him honk when he runs away. He goes
Sorry volzmer and satan are the same person obviously
satan I walked outside we went into the movie tether where they were showing to exorcists
In it a boy and girl were doing it suddenly a serial killer came. I don't
Was that in the extra? I don't remember that say and I laughed at the blood cuz we're sadists
I'm like, I don't think there's a is there a serial killer in the exorcist?
I just my lead am I am I losing it?
Um
While any kills actual serial he's just like cailing cheerios
While satan was watching the movie I had an idea
I took satan's gothic black nightmare before christmas cigar
cigar
He is a nightmare before christmas themed cigar
Sexily from his pocket and put some amnesia potion in it
I put it back in his black amiel the strange bag
satan turned around and started to smoke it in the movie theater he just started smoking a cigar
Black clouds with red pentagrams and them started to fly around everywhere
OMG satan said jumping up I gasped cuz I was afraid he noticed and no but guess what
I knew that the amnesia had worked
Amnesia potion has not been invented yet so it will not work
He said too bad cuz I wanted to use somebody wait what?
It hasn't been invented yet so it can't work
Yes, it can if I bring something from the from the future to the past it's still gonna be functional
Unless it's like technology
Like a cell phone
I
Truly has a written work
Um
Cool I raised my eyes
Suggestingly and then he stopped wait what he I just tried to roofie him and now he's taken off my cloak
All right
You just roll with the punches I guess and then he took off my clothes sexily. We started to make out
I took off his shit. He had a six pack just like gerard way. We frenched
Sorry
I fucking choked during the bit. I'm so sorry
I'm good
Excuse me, but you're gonna have to leave. She did the lady behind us. She was a prep
Fuck you. I said suddenly I attacked her sucking all her blood
No
She screamed all the preps into theaters screamed but everyone else crapped
Cuz satan and I looked so cute together satan I started wait they crapped or they clapped and it's a whole plane
Clapped when it landed and I started to walk outside
It's the omg it's omg. How did you do that?
Omg, how did you do that for the more ass and it turned on voice? Oh, I'm so turned on
I'm a vampire. I said as we went to the car
Seriously, he asked. Yeah, seriously. I said drinking some beer saying
Where did I get the beer saying started to drive the car? I smelled happily
It's too bad because we didn't get to see the rest of the movie. Don't you think?
Yeah, I said as we kissed passively
Satan parked in the black driveway next to the place where drake gona had watched gc for the first time
We went inside where maryland manson was
Playing and started to mosh lol
Anti people now
Have gone too far jesus christ superstar. I can't remember how that song goes
Scream martin marlin on the stage. He did the devil fingers. Hold on
And we're rocking out. Let me just I need to rock out
Where is it? Where's my devil horns?
Nope
There we go. I don't know why it's named that don't ask me why
I know you can't see it, but the devil horns are named straight jacket for some reason
I don't know why I named it that
I don't know why I named them straight jacket
Nemo's dad marlin he's he's at the he's he's there. He's singing on stage
Uh
I started to dance really close to satan. He was so schmuck say he looked at me. I forget. What's his face that plays?
Voldemort
I
Ralph fiends
Young Ralph fiends
Oh my god, actually wait, hold on you guys can't see
Uh
Look at that. So this is young Voldemort everybody. This is what you're seeing right here. This is satan
This is satan
We're all pretending that this is
I'm trying to find like an emo picture like a goth looking version
What
I don't really think that one works
Perfect we love to see it
Male male on stream male cry harder. Oh my god, it's I'm showing Voldemort. I'm showing the Voldemort actor
Three people who are sad
It's all please you know, I love you shot up
It's over. She be canceled. I broke my contract. I think it actually it does say in my contract. I can't interact with men
Like me too
Biological men
It's so ship over
I'm losing my job. I'm literally gonna get fired straw. He is messaging me saying that I'm done
Guys I've been I've been let go. I'm so sorry. I've just been terminated. I have to end stream
It was an honor knowing you all
Um, it's been great. It's been great playing she be for you guys
Uh
Oh, wait, wait. Nope. Johnny said I can finish the stream. But then afterwards I I have to leave
I have to pack my bags and go. I am not America's next top. Uh model. So
It's been cool. It's been great. Um, let me just continue this
That works with that emo with the salute
Mmm, that's some good water
High face beautiful girl for you watermelon you just offer me a watermelon
What?
What is your fucking name?
What am I I just have a fucking conniption reading that anyways, um
You you're new to cb stream you come in. I just fucking roast you
I'm like, this is the thanks I get
This is the thanks I get for coming in. I'm sorry
Um
I'm gonna see anytime a new person talks. I'm just gonna roast them now anytime. I don't recognize someone
I'm just gonna start hating on them for no reason and I'm gonna gatekeep myself
I'm gatekeeping myself
Pretty sure it's a bot. Yeah, I know
But just in case it's not
Oh, me next go who the fuck are you?
What did you come from you're just talking because I said all gray names
Gray names gray name alert gray name gold mask get them sick. I'm boy
More work work work work work work work
That's why I don't chat chat and type for real. No, you you type in chat when you want attention because he's a little bitch
You're like, oh, she'll call if she'll say something to me if I talk right now. Yeah
There you go
The grace come out at night including yourself
Poor poor get your money up son
Five dollars and you can save a starving child in america by the name of sheevy cotton bum
All right
In the arms of an angel
For only five dollars a month you too can support a streamer
Who streams as v tubing a vtuber character for a living?
And that's how she gets her money
Find them she we are
Oh, it's fine. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's a bit. It's a bit everybody. It's a bit
It's a bit
It's a bit stop put your credit card down. Just put your mom's credit card away. Stop it
Anyways, let me continue reading to the poor people. Um
Satan parked in a black driveway. Why does it have to be a black drive away?
Isn't it concrete next to plazor draco?
And I watched gc for the first time he went sour maryland manson was playing and started to mosh
I wonder if anybody I can make anybody cry. I would like to make someone cry on my stream
I think that's my goal. I want to make someone cry
Or was I that wasn't up there?
Um, I want to like bully someone so bad. I make them cry. I think that's pretty I think it's pretty uncharacter for me
You know
Making if I just like oh, you're such a little bitch. Oh crying little bitch, you know, I cry every stream
Yeah, because you think I'm funny
I
New viewer gifted. What is that face? Did you draw that on a notebook?
Did you copy one of those how to draw manga?
books
Thank you for the gifted
I like how
Wink wink 9000 I'm gonna do like like a butthole a butthole winks. Yep. That's all I got
I
It's an older drawing
I'm sorry, you came at a bad time where I'm roasting people
I'm crying I'm reefing crying is what we do. That's true. That's true reeflings are little cry babies
little babies and it's funny because like
I
Strawny supposed to be like not super dumb like she's like she's a she you guys don't get it
Shawnee's a sub
Like I don't I'm scrawny all the time in our discord chats. You guys don't get to see them
But I have her chained up tied
Uh, I whip her and she's great. You guys like
You guys gotta step up and be men, you know, you're not taking care of your your cuttlefish gold mask is on my desk
um
Little dented cry babies. Hi gold mask
How's it going gold mask sniff the mic sniff the mic
All right, bye gold mask
Reeflings are super subs. Yeah, they way they waited a year now. They're all cry babies. I'm a reefling awkward
Tuck's a hair behind ear. Um
Have you tried to hypnotize you know go away boy
Don't wink at me like a fucking predator enough
She beats the biggest sap. I don't know what you're talking about. I'm shibony
Thank you pookie my only mod because she's not even like a mod mod. She's just my friend
My mods are asleep because I usually stream at 4 p.m. Eastern time
Oh
My god, the reeflings are throwing up. No, don't throw up reeflings. Don't throw up in my chat
Don't bring your your disease here. I don't know what std's you guys carry
uh
Gross just kidding. I love all you guys. I love everybody doesn't matter who you are reefling harem pin pal snowberry
Uh bleeding heart senpai. Don't worry. You guys are great
I see that I'm just I'm just reassuring you right now because I know some of you are gonna take what I say out of
Text and seriously so I have to like
Remind you guys that I've been doing a bit this entire stream
And now I'm gonna go back into being shibony. Okay. Fuck all of you. You're all bitches
Yeah, we did they just cleaned they just cleaned the hotel you guys are puking everywhere. I have to read you the carpet
You collab idea proposal should be tries to instruct a reefling and into how to dumb scrawny
Feels miserably because reefling is too much of a sub everyone laughs
That's it
Smell does not come out not the carpet
Where was I
I
Okay, suddenly wait
He looked at me wait
I started to dance really close to satan. We're going back to the story shut up everyone
I
Started to dance really close to satan. He was so schmech say he looked at me all emo with his gothic red eyes
And he looked exactly like Mikey way. I almost got an orgasm. Suddenly Marilyn Manson stopped singing. I
Would like to present
X black X tier X one one. He said I'm not gonna do a Marilyn Manson voice
I ran on stage. I just smelled my own part
I actually smelled really good
damn
I don't know what it is guys. I think just like
I haven't worn deodorant in like
three days
Haven't shaved my pits and I think I smell pretty good
What the fresh hell is this your name is the booty lord
You don't have a right to speak
Who are you wreathling?
pathetic
Go throw up somewhere else. Anyways
You guys don't see me, but I'm gripping the motherfucking mic as I'm I'm holding it and I'm moving it around and I'm moving my body around and you guys can't see
Madam is such a tease
Madam's not here. It's shippity now
Man's gone
I
Anyways
I ran on stage Lucy and Samro snap and Hades were there
They started to play their instruments. I got on stag. I thought I was already there, but I'm not
um
Well, if you wanted honesty that's all you had to say
I sang I did not own delirics to that song
My voice sounded like a pentagram between Amy across instead of across the pentagram get it because I'm gothic
um, Amy Lee and a girl version
of gerard boy
His uh, asian counterpart everyone clapped satan got an ever expectation. He got an erection of re-sing. I'm not
Okay
I'm not
Yeah, it was a weak one. I know shut the fuck up. I sang finally suddenly lucian started playing this song wrong by mistak
Oh my fucking god yielded james. What the fuck?
Whoops. I'm sorry. So lucian was making them all sound like one direction people
You're fucking also james started you angrily. You guys are such prep. You guys are such prep wait
You guys are such prep snap said come on. It was a mistake. Yeah, it's not his fault. So serious
Now you're in the fucking song. You know samaro
You guys stop I shooted angrily, but it was too late. They all began to fight
Suddenly samaro took out his knife. Oh my fucking god. No
Star started lucian was too late james started to shoot off his arm
And then I jumped sexily in front of the bullet
Yeah
Hold on. Let me I just cracked my neck. I don't know if you think you guys hear that
This is me blocking the bullet except I'm behind the thing so you can't see me getting shot right now
No
Oh
I blocked it
Shibini super aggro I was aggroed. I'm aggroed. I was sick
Well, I'm still have really bad allergies. I'm surprised. I'm not sneezing. I took like two
Freakin allergy pills and I'm probably gonna die because it said only take one within like two hours
And I took like a bunch and I'm like
Uh, not a bunch
In minecraft, uh, let me continue before I get canceled
for
Huff and Benadryl, um
No yielded everyone but it was too late everything went black
went Blake
Chapter 39 we have one two three four five more chapters after this. Can you believe that guys?
Oh
Yeah, um someone hacked my account when I was writing the story and they wrote this
Disclaimer I do not own the hp series and I am not the real xs bloody risk six six xx six
Authors note. I am an extremely immature pathetic idiot girl. I know out of boredom
I cracked this girl's pasty for fun and it took less than eight minutes to do it too
I probably get a shitload of trouble
Which I probably deserve because I'm being a troll right now
Meh anyways, I prefer to send to you my crappy part in the story and take note
I haven't finished reading this fic yet, but instead skim over to skip chat skim chapter 38 flame laugh
Do whatever you want preps
I the American retail wearing British vampire sue coughed up blood satan kneeled down beside me
No, don't die. I gave him a rueful smile
I'm sorry
It's something I had to do to fulfill my duty as noble gothic mary sue satan sobbed. I love you ebony
I love you too. I'll
I'll see you in hell. I mumbled already finding my surroundings fading to black
Bloody mary smith suddenly popped into the room for no apparent reason
She frown when she realized the room was oddly quiet, but the sight of ebony's life was body. She screamed
Her face became pale of horror. She screamed for the healers dumbledore mcgoogle and every single gothic person so you could think of
Suddenly a glow started to surround the body of ebony
Everyone scared stared in shock. Her body started to lift ever so slowly and then to everyone's shock. It started to incinerate
When everyone realized what was happening. They rushed over to try to rescue the body, but it was too late
The sue became nothing more than a pile of ashes
A loud resounding of everyone bellowing
No
filled the room
A flash of white light from the ashes and started to bounce around the room
Everyone cowered in fear and they were temporarily blinded when it was all over things changed
Like this if you cry every time
All the silly goth clothes dropped from everyone's bodies
Office note
I will refuse to explain how the hell it happened and in their place closed the characters were normally wearing cannon appeared on their bodies
When everyone got over the shock and becoming free of the gothic power
Everybody cheered everyone started singing ding dong the sue is dead
Well, that is until the hp characters realized the true implications of becoming more cannon like again
All the characters were supposed to be dead fell to the floor their body is cold and lifeless
Harry and voldemort started dueling on the left side of the two the battle of the light side of the dark side of our reaching a climax
And because the replacement author also looks to screw with cannon drink of her mining flood the scene and got married
Meanwhile down in hell at me she had a single tear because of her current situation
A situation that she would live in for all eternity or at least until the end of fan fiction time
Now you can actually read
What in the world?
Don't ask a harlot. Don't ask
Um, she lost it all but she knew she had to remain strong. Nothing would ever break her down
She looked down over her pale body and frowned
Where are my email clothes? She asked herself in confusion
Then it occurred to her for her shirt. She was wearing a bright pink polo with a little seagull on the right side
Below that she was wearing a denim miniskirt with destroyed look on it paired underneath that skirt with leggings with a little mousse at the bottom
And then ebony realized on her shoulder. She was carrying a pretty bag with an eagle that said live your life written all over the bag
Ebony suppressed the urge to scream
Here she was decked out in pro clothes perhaps to the extreme wearing stuff from erber copy and fitch
american eagle and
Hollister
Panicked ebony hastily tried to take off the holster polar but underneath it
There was another holster polo underneath ebony frown and looked under her shirt
All she saw was a bra underneath dare. I point out that it's from airy line available at american eagle
They have nice bras
Uh, ebony tried to remove the shirt again. They're very comfy actually
Uh, but to her frustration there was not yet an again another polo to replace it
This is unlogical and doesn't make any sense
Ebony bellowed out into the air. She failed to see the irony in her statement
How hypocritical her words were seeing as she was practically calling the kettle black here
Ebony slit her wrists and mumbled to herself. Oh my god
Cooch my gooch
Oh
What the fuck it's my government name your family hates you. Uh, anyways
And crap fic. Oh if you want to see original content this chicken plant for this chapter
I assess it through the document manager thingy, which I copied and pasted so you can read it here. Okay, so now we're back
Now we're back. I'm sweating
Any a paper towel
My
Cooch my gooch is sweating
Hi gold mask
How are you doing over here?
Welcome to member
Back to what
Welcome to the club. You're not even in the club. You're a stray pin pal
And that's okay
We accept all refugees of multiple fan bases here even outside of velar. Okay
Because we just want love here bros love just kidding. Fuck all of you. Um, I woke up and uh, oh
Cooch
Thank you. Cooch my gooch. Oh my god. Cooch my gooch. Gooching out right now. It's a 20 gifted. Let's go poggers in the chat
Dubs say thank you if you got one
She hates
I'm a gray no longer you've been
Oh a lot of people have been blessed
A lot of people have been blessed
Get blessed
Get blessed by Cooch my gooch
Nice gifted the gifted hit
Yeah, let's go. Thank you
New he just like I just make fun of his name and then he just
And then he just gives I guess it's working. I guess it's working guys
Thanks, Cooch
And so that's how emmy says pookie. I'm gonna start calling you guys coochie
Anybody so big hi coochies. Oh my god. Hi coochies
Okay, could you could you come?
Um, whoa, bro. What the heck?
He's trying to hit the gray names in here, dude
Thank you again for the
20 gifted cooch my gooch
He's like, you know, I got some disposable income. I'm gonna drop it on this baddie
Aka me right here
Thank you
He's going ape shit. He's going cooch shit. That's what I'm saying
Bully cooch harder for more gifted he's
Oh, you're so uh
Your gooch is
Know what? I'm gonna talk about something the gooch
Uh, I've I've I've I've gone into detail before about how I hate male anatomy because there's too much of a distance
Between the balls and the butthole for a guy called the gooch
The uh, what else is it called?
The the the the desert plane, you know, I don't know
It's not cool. It's not cool. It should be closer
The taint. Yes
the tainted love
Sainted love by Marilyn Manson, you know
um
Like it does too much space there. It's too much space. There should be a pussy there
Men men should have pussies there
Uh
Don't ask me why
I'm just saying uh in that space
Just so you guys can all just be you know food is the grundle. Thank you the cabbage patch kid if you will
um
Go on
Is that where it is? Uh
Yeah, uh get rid of it. Uh slap a slap a pussy on there and I think you'll be fine the brown mile. That's a good one
Uh
And yeah, once once you guys get that I think you'll be cool in my book. Oh, yeah, that just makes you a fuda
That's true. That makes you a fuda, but you know just so like you have some so much extra space
You have so much extra space just put something there, you know
I'm gonna get get a tattoo get a tattoo of a get like a get a get a temporary tattoo
uh
Of a of a coochie coochie coo
Slap it on your gooch and send me a picture
That's all I want
Send me a picture of your gooch with the with the coochie tattoo
That's what I'm asking for you park your car there. That's where your peanut sign. What?
You know people are gonna do this that why do you think i'm asking? I know they're gonna do it
I've gone videos of guys sticking their balls in soy sauce. Of course, they're gonna do it
Because I asked guys and I can't you can you taste?
Soy sauce with the balls and I need I need proof you got it somebody told me that you can do that
And then I got videos of it and I was like sick
Now give me more like I don't know
Where in my marrows bro my marshmallows marshmallows dash qa
forward slash
Dot coms forward slash a sheebie cotton bum
Send me your gooch
Only only with a coochie tattoo though
temporary
Go find it on like timu or something
AliExpress probably has that don't just send me your gooch. I don't care about that
I want you to at least or just draw something on it fill the space with something important
Property of sheebie that's also a good idea
She's grown too powerful
The face you can put it you can you can you can um make a temporary tattoo of my face and put it there
Mickey mouse clip art sounds great
Artistic gooch only that's what I'm talking about
Yes, they stick the smug face on it
I think you're overestimating how much space is actually there
Do you already have a pussy then?
I've seen I've seen gay porn. There's a lot of space
There's a lot of space
All right
Like I said gay porn instead of just regular porn
Oh
Anyways free parking I'm gonna park my strap there
But I need to know where I'm parking so
Draw a little car on it draw your little car in your parking space. I'm giving you so many ideas
You can draw like like a little like a little hot dog like the other end
Like a hot dog in a blanket
Draw a cat draw a dog
And be like I got that dog in me bark bark
Taking a pig with the hot wheels take a pig with a with a tech deck
Just start grinding on that
She'd be you thought like you go stick was down lower
You thought I I did research afterwards. I'm just I have like what's it called?
like
What's it called?
It's like I have something blindness like I can't remember things properly. So like I'll see something
But I don't remember it how I should remember it like my headcanon just takes over
So now I'm picturing your your giggle stick is like right near your belly button now. Isn't it up towards there? I don't remember
You're artistic. I'm not artistic. I'm acoustic get it right
There's space so it's not a landing strip then make it into a landing strip
I don't know what to tell you
Yeah, put a whole storage unit in I'll take a tour
You know
MTV welcome to my crib like come on except welcome to my taint come on guys
What's going on here
Do you really want to know I didn't say on the belly button I said below the belly button
I
Need someone to draw a picture of me with a magnifying glass looking at your gooch
Goochie goochie go
Renala is on my lap kind of want to know you kind of don't
All right, she be you got to pick one caller three name on it or she be branded gooch tattoo, uh
I would prefer the caller
To be honest with you
But that's a hard question
This whole conversation is because that guy's name I had told you I'm acoustic
I don't like you say one word I'm gonna go in a tangent for 20 minutes
I feel like you need a mannequin to have a constant reference of correct anatomy
Then I'll just start humping the mannequin
Just give me a male sex doll at that point
One word
Ten bars ten seconds five bars five seconds cinnamon women all men
All men are friends
What's my favorite sexual company
I don't fucking know. I'm not a dude
I just get a dildo when I'm fine. I don't need a doll
Where am I gonna put that?
My family's gonna come over and I'm just gonna have like harem doll on the couch
I'm like, hi. This is my new boyfriend. He he
They'll be like, how did you even afford this because those things are like $2,000
I just dress them up take them on dates
You know, this is actually sounding like an appealing idea
Like if I was a dude
I feel like it's more socially acceptable for a man to have a doll but not a woman, you know, I just thought about that
I don't know why that is
Shoving in the closet. I have no space in my closet. I have no space in my house
That's why the human dog bed is just on my couch all the time and I've been sleeping. I haven't slept on my bed in like two weeks
I've just been sleeping in the human dog bed. I need to clean that thing
So confused right now as you should
Your parents are cool. They accept us as a doll. Uh, they would probably send me to the psych ward again. That's what they would do
groupie sock vacation
part three
wink
You need to clean that thing you should clean out your flashlight
How about that it's crusty sitting on your bed. It's starting to have mold in it, bro. You gotta get rid of that
Speaking of which check out my patreon for 18 plus audios where I
Know
oh my god are we back? Jesus ouch! I spunked my head on the mic. I don't even know what
happened what just freaking happened oh my god I don't know what happened I just
crawled under my table and just like hoped stuff and hoped that it did
something and it did so we're fine anyways
it wasn't gold mask we are so back you're a bit quiet I think cuz it went on a
different hold on hold on hold on my mic my mic is turned up all the way
but I think my go XLRs oh what the hell the cable get pinched I don't think so
nothing's working bro I'm getting fucking cramps oh I'm keeping a woman
the squish mellow the squish mellows far away am I better now does it sound
louder my good does it sound can you hear me sounds kind of shaky like your
parents marriage I don't know better but quiet that's so fucking weird
I don't know what fucking happened I don't know what happened
we're trying a lot I'm feeling spicy cuz stuff isn't working I'm taking out my
anger on you does this sound better you said you were grabbing at the mic no my
hands were down I'm getting so many follows what the frick is happening who
are these people stop I 14k followers randomly why why does that tweet have
6.6 likes bro why does this tweet have 6.6 likes can these fucks follow my
YouTube can all the people who liked this tweet follow my YouTube I need to
catch up to strongy and Emmy Emmy probably never I'm not a cunny but it's
fine you mean did a 26k what on my alt snow fucking way oh my god what the hell
I was complaining for such a long time I'm like this is dick do I gotta suck to
suck some dick I mean six to get 25k around here that I am 26k
everybody hates my small ass I'm so low because of my small booty cheeks my
small booty cheeks small booty cheeks I'm I'm booty cheeked up what about my blue
website that that pop off to that'd be sick no I think I got like 80 more
followers sick I like the feet no the feet didn't even it was literally that
one tweet the feet got like 1.4 likes and then the me saying I'm so sorry if my
alt account comes across you if you're coomer enjoy if you're not just mute it
I don't know how that gets 6.6 likes I don't understand that 2.2 wait what did
it get 2.2 bro I'm going to commit that can't be right can we get me a 15k on
main I'd be fucking sick actually colleagues people just follow my feet I
mean follow my account not follow my feet 1.9 okay cool strong he says 2.1
sick let's go I was hoping we started trained but we all the other
video posted separately the blue is 2.2 I'm not I need to stop eating deep
jerky make my tummy hurt
also where'd you get the hat this is suss etsy specially made
I even know where the hat went I put it away and I don't know where it went I
just have short-term memory loss what do you want gold mask I'm staring at you
yeah go away back off you're making me feel you I feel threatened what are you
doing hello hat disappeared kind of suss just a dog well he doesn't want food
he's just like walking around me anyways what the shibbity I woke up into
okay we're starting we're starting pay attention lock in where am I hold on
I'll jingle some keys at you so I can get your attention
little acoustic baby you want some keys you want some keys little baby boy you
want some keys oh hi Sarah lock in lock in oh you want some keys oh I got the
booboo keys for you we're subway sir oh I got you hold on let's let's let's let's
let me let me lock you guys in hello Raiders hi my name is shibbiny darkness
dementia way I am she be cotton bums and niece and I'm reading a fanfiction
today but let me just throw on some stuff to keep you guys enraptured hold on I
have you closely to my heart I'm looking I'm looking hold on it's my take a
moment first let's get this let's get this going nice alright let's one
we're gonna zoomer this out
let's see here let's see here perfect perfect we love it here I'm gonna put
them next to you guys so you guys feel safe don't ask me why I already have
all this on my computer you don't need to know um oh this is perfect this is
perfect for this lovely all perfect let's get that there I should you're
right I should get some family guy clips should definitely get some family guy
clips uh what the frick where are all my zoomer images oh I got this this work
for you that is that get you going we're playing wizard 101 that's what we're
doing put that right there why do I have all this on my computer you guys don't
know how zoomer I am I hide my power level
I'll put this around you cuz I love you guys not really look it to you I'm I'm
still going by the way I'm still pulling up stuff
um nope that's a that's a dildo can't put that there no oh perfect I got the
fidget spinner for you this is this keeping your attention what why are you
looking at me like that
blah blah oh wait should I do that
hmm
looking for more stuff to put oh my god my neighbors children are walking by
I say walking I mean they're running and screaming I got a laser
this is pretty cool I rotate this so it looks like it's shooting out of my hand
shibidi toilet I don't have any shibidi toilets I can look for skibidi toilet
they burn what are you watching this in the black room and just only my screen is two inches from your face
yeah what's wrong with all of you
I have a picture of this it's not me but it is me it's my pl but I like how it was edited
hold on let me get some uh let me get
it subway surfer our caps lock on compilation
oh perfect I don't care about ads
ads
lovely oh my god let's go
hold on I need I need family guy I need family guy I need family guy
family guy shorts compilation
perfect perfect let me just window capture oh we love to see it oh
oh
what why isn't this doing this
there we go
now we're living like Larry nope that's not what I wanted to move
why is this so hard to do
gold mask get off my desk
trying to see let me put this here
should probably get neopets up
that's pretty cool where's the sound fine
I'm gonna blast it blanche hey it's off it's off it's off it's off
throw this phone away Lois but I haven't seen mom since she took me back to school shopping
all right sweetie you're ready to get some new notebooks and protractors and slacks I want blue
jeans you're getting slacks get out of the fucking car get out of the fucking car right now man
did we just carjack someone we should did Brian we should do
but get out of this place one day hey butch get a load of stewie he says he's gonna get out of here
hahaha you don't know me man I'm different I got ideas hey butch you hear that stewie's got ideas
shut up I'm gonna go I can't play both at the same time on the other side I'm gonna be a singer
boob lay over here says he's gonna be a singer hey boob lay I gotta tune for you to sing it's called
get nightmare nightmare nightmare nightmare nightmare epilepsy epilepsy nightmare nightmare
nightmare nightmare those guys follow your heart shut up I can't do both let me
it literally and legitimately won't let me
okay now I will I just couldn't see it this new slab now we're good my name is Chris you don't
have a name until I give you one I was like this or let a young and plump to be in a place like this
this is gauging can you hear me over the memes someone who could provide you with protection
hey hello I could be your friend hello Chris what's the latest with your little guy
hi I don't think this is a lot should I get some more fidget spinners
Mrs. Lockhart you teach her whoa whoa whoa whoa do you want some apple juice you need some apple
juice you need some whoa you need some quailudes I don't even know what that means
this sounds like a funny word I just know it's a drug or some ketamine
wow we sound amazing to get it was I muted I don't even know you know we should do something
when we got scared by my open up a mattress door or we could try singing me it's okay that's good
dig I'm a hungry baby there's a granola bottle I hope you enjoy it do you like the stream so far
hey is it good what's this what's going on am I talking to myself up there oh my god
stewie just shut up can you hear me do you know what I do Meg I speak in your mouth while you sleep
it's time to help people touch the mic he's still here I'm gonna be a woman at work it cannot get
so with me sweetie maybe you need to go home
I was muted for a little while yeah because it's because boomy sat on my mute button
put it back on you're not quite distracted your brain running this is pretty good setup
I'm not gonna lie I'm kind of I might save this as like a layout
I don't even know what the frick is playing on my desktop audio you're watching Family Guy
I want six more fidget spinners all right I got you
oh hold on
I think I want one more fidget spinner
nice all right um
going full on png youtuber
oh you know what I want I think I want
I want I want I wanted this
stupid game ads
I
don't want people reacting I just want to see them Nord VPN everybody
who is this random dude I just want the games I don't want this dude
I just want mobile games
perfect
I'm pretty good now I'm feeling pretty good
good this is this is pretty cool
can't even see what's happening on the screen anymore
what should I buy a pig in boots
should play the game that recreates you should yes is that a game like that
another just fake another just fake
why don't I have a million subscribers yet that's my question I really don't get it
okay let me turn up the volume for you
this is pretty nice I'm feeling pretty good
uh you can see why I was hired
I was hired for a reason hold on let me move let's move Rena out of the way this is perfect let's put me
in there there we go that's pretty good
can't wait for this video to be acclaimed like 50 times not that I care all of the Maya mortal
reading fanfiction ones by the way got like limited so hard
looks a lot better I agree this is pretty cool looks like I'm just lasering
oh should I get out my gun get out my gun
wait no I should flip it
there we go
yeah I'm shooting fidget spinners at you let's go
doing the bite and blast can I play these games on stream look awesome I kind of want to play them
on stream except what's happening I don't even know what's happening in some of these
he just hatched a turtle no don't be mean to the turtle what the hell
I'm a level 10 giat dragon
in most these games are fake like your parents love for you
why does that cat just stare that's what my cats do that cat looks like it's high as fuck
why should pee with the skirt on what do you mean it's a fucking skirt you could just sit on the toilet
and lift it up I don't understand you can pee with the skirt on I don't have to remove the entire skirt
oh this is a great stream
something tells me this isn't gonna be the end of my immortal yeah it is
I should finish the rest of the thing should I finish it like this
did you guys get all the screenshots that your heart could desire
be like this is my oh she this is what she does
how do I delete all this shit
oh
I accidentally threw myself across my bedroom
can I select
tonight
all right you guys are you ready
this is the overlay this is the overlay to
coffee
oh I'm taking myself with me
no I don't want fucking let me take off my hand
stop oh my god for the love of Christ let me unlock this
I'm just
it's all gone oh hi
hi there
Amiyoshi
oh I'm gonna get her stupid thing
where'd my mouse go my mouse is gone I can't even see my mouse oh there it is
what the hell that was so weird unless it turned into like a thing I don't know
uh let's get rid of that
am I am I talking oh my god it's you guys oh paul gurus I'm on tv look you guys you can see yourself
I suddenly feel empty I know it feels quieter when you take your meds doesn't it
doesn't it hey you guys want to see something cool
fuck it didn't work
no it's not working
damn it
I was hoping I could I could just show everything again but it didn't let me it just like completely
removed reacting to my own broadcast and be mostly just me just like just making the
that one wojak face
kind of want to bake cookies again I only made like I literally just made five cookies
when I baked cookies the other day yesterday live she be reaction I should get like an overlay
that looks like a camera like uh like a blinking red light and be like live she be reaction
you like the cookie I bake for you guys although I know you guys will just leave me
that's fine it's cool I know you guys don't really love me I know it's all just a fake to you
I know you guys just use me for uh just your own personal pleasure it's fine it's whatever
it's cool I accepted that um you love the fit thank you uh you know it's cool it's cool it's fine
it's fine I still I still love you anyways even though you don't love me it's cool it's fine um
it's cool it's fine it's whatever but my small but I'm unlovable I know I'm kind of useless uh
I'm a terrible dom I'm a horrible person I suck at my job I don't know how any of you follow me
but it's fine uh it's cool
all right let me let's we should continue before you know I just like make catch a package on stream
um cool if you really love me
no never mind
please don't like please don't break up to me or I'll I'll kill myself a Minecraft
I woke up into Norse's office on a special gothic coffin
Harigrid was in the bed opposite me in a comma because Vampire and Draco had bed him up
Mr. Norse is cleaning the room
oh me Satan what happened I screamed suddenly Volzemort came
he looked yet less mean than usual get the fuck out you fucking bastard oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're all lying to me it's whatever
where's my gamer so I'm tired of drinking random water
I was being
the Benny's what's the Benny's it's all about the Benjamin's baby I don't know what those images
what do you want gold mask gold mask is looking at me all concerned
should we already jealous of gen 2 no I'm not worried about gen 2 I never worry about the other
girl I worry about the guy I worry about you
like I know I'll be Tyler gen 2 they'll be my baby girls they'll be my baby girl pookie girls
they'll be my baby dolls but you guys you're just gonna up and leave like everybody else does
that's how it is that's what that's what they always do they always leave
they always leave me fully I was cunning then I would be loved
if only I was cute and funny people love me if only if I was what they wanted to me if only I
was what I was a dummy mommy if only if I was uh a true if only if I was the people the person
that started off if only if I wasn't black you would love me if I wasn't black but it's fine
all of myself all of myself
yeah you'd love me if I had a bbl
you don't love me because I'm a dork
look at the levels of my head up
should we stop the quarter twitter crowd will hear they can hear
they can hear let them hear you don't really love me
anyways
it's got a really dizzy am I gonna pass out
volzumor oh my fucking god what's wrong I asked suddenly lucian professor sister in
serious came blotty mary and vampire were with them everyone was holding black boxes volzumor
disappeared
my sister date a black guy that's not true and he's dating a black guy
what that's a that's that's fake news
I'd be impressed if there's one black dude watching emmy
I just picture them all as a little white skinny white boys
chat would you love she be if she was a worm true would you love me if I was a worm
huh
what do you picture us as uh
I guess I just all pick I picture everybody's fan base as just doujinshi faceless white
protagonist
was just super long hair I'm pretty sure I tweeted that out at one point
is there a black pimple I don't know maybe
yeah I just treat what she be on you're brown
are so many people brown I brown people watching me that's pretty sick I'm brown too did you know that
how can you see through my camera because I hacked it bro
babe babe it's madame you fuck
tell yeah
my my fan base we're diverse in here we hit that diversity quota thanks for your goofiness
I got injured at work you make me google through the pain oh no how did you get injured at work
you better get that workers comp honey get that workers comp thank you for the $10
save your money save for the medical bills girly pop
my little kuchi remember I'm gonna start calling you guys kuchi
should we tell him tell him what that you're a gay harlot
she really doesn't know that much about harem I don't
wonder if she yeah you guys don't love me is mine oh cold mask ladies is laying next to me
hi gold man oh you're nice and cozy and turned on my oven so I can bake cookies
I got I got friendzoned
you call me shabro I'm getting friendzoned I showed you my ass I'm getting friendzoned
showed you my feet I'm getting friendzoned
she be I'm with that new friend I only started engaging with the vealer community and I really
enjoy my time here I'll definitely make a habit of visiting you and everyone you want to talk to me
after this you actually enjoy my content after watching me for the last two hours
what can I do a backflip no wait wait actually no I got you I got you I got you I got you I got
you I got you I got you I got you I got you I got you I got you kuchi wait I'm coming back around
I'm coming back around oh let's take the landing get rekt
you see that shit bro I want X games bro is on X games brother
viewers are discussing the race of she be a character from the haul live en community
I'm in hall alive oh my god guys I'm in hall alive I would like to
you think uh pekara for always telling me I could do my best uh in tomagotchi form
like she talks to me um or it's just because I haven't taken my meds it's fine um I like to
thank her I like to take thank hosho marine for teaching me how to be a tasteful hoe uh I would
like to thank um you know elizabeth rose blood flame for teaching me how to do wacky voices uh
kiyara for you know to you know teaching me how to be entertaining um so many good girls
in hall alive I'm so excited to be in hall alive um yeah guys uh it's all a ruse vealer is actually
a branch of hall alive uh we didn't want to tell it to you guys like this but um it's true we are
almost like we're like regloss except we're horse uh it's pretty crazy uh the secret shadow c
oh vealer is yagu guys I just I'm so glad to tell you guys I'm so glad I could get that off my chest
I'm clapping get me pregnant get me pregnant get me pregnant oh yes oh sorry um uh I'm I'm gonna be
deejaying a breaking no sorry ice he's gonna be deejaying I'm gonna be dancing as a backup dancer
uh at uh breaking dimensions uh I'll just be like twerking I'll be a backup dancer
hollow cure was foreshadowing hollow alert that's it guys we're hollow alert I don't
I'm sorry I'm sorry you've been lying to you guys strongy is yagu
what do you as if we ever had a chance why would I get the hollow collab if I'm already in hollow
are you kidding me who am I the closest to um let me think
sorry I was drinking hold on
who am I the closest to in hollow live
well I'm dating Shiori novella I mean no I'm not what's no
um uh I won't lie to you guys um more
I was gonna say something man um Maury's my sister from another mister uh I do like hanging out with
Fuyamoko
um Gigi Mirren's pretty sick Cecilia Emmergreen also my girlfriend I mean what
Kosaki Biju uh rock uh keeper in my pocket Saraswana mom uh Orokroni babe uh Natasha
Nanashi Mume also babe Hako's Bells babe Iris ultimate babe uh Gragura um she's my daughter
Watson Amelia girlfriend
Ina girlfriend Chiara Bestie Gigi Bestie um ERB older sister Rihara my art teacher Narissa wife
Sanna dead
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry recipe Sanna I miss you so much you're the only brown girl
a first round Gorbo girl
why would the vaude be gone why would the vaude be gone why would I get rid of the vaude
why would I get rid of the vaude the vaude's been pretty normal
she was I said she's the first she was the first she paved the way
she's dead she you're wrong for that everybody's I'm gonna get cancelled because I said Sanna's dead
I'm sorry she's graduated I loved her too
I'm pouring one out I'm pouring one out you're gonna hear it I'm pouring one out for Sanna hold on
pouring
poured one out for Sanna the OG no I did not just piss into something
love her like a sister
that's some good shibby name
it's shib over it's groomer what
it's grover I gotta fart guys do you guys hate me you guys hate me you guys hate me you guys hate
me now you hate me you hate me you hate me you hate me you hate me it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine you hate me it's fine it's fine I'm just gonna go
I just had my anger here, I just had my anger here, I just had my anger here, I just had
you guys hurt me so much
Oh, hey my cookies are ready to be put in hold on
it's apiece of cookies I baked a pretty cake
I love you, and I miss you, home.
Home.
Why does that one thing go?
I love you, and I forget how it goes.
I just have one one thing go.
Country boy, I love you, and that's what it was.
That's what I was looking for.
My neighbors probably hate me.
Oh my god.
There it is.
And I make cookies for love and everything and things delight me.
Siri said a timer for 12 minutes.
Thank you.
The chocolate chip cookies.
Am I good? I'm fine.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm totally fine.
Is that how I passed the audition?
Oh wait, can I pull up my audition video? Hold on.
Let's see if I can do that again.
I remember last time it wasn't working.
Let's see if it will work this time.
Let's see. No, that's not what I wanted.
I don't know.
Let's see.
I go into here and then I go into here and then I go into here.
I like the way she do it right there, right there.
What's up?
Wait, where the fuck?
Where's the original?
Wait, it's in here.
Is this it?
I don't think this is it.
Oh, wait, no, that's a bestie.
Well, up.
Hi.
Oh.
Down, girl.
Let's watch my audition.
Look, it's me as Rena.
Everybody knows that.
Copyright.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, it's me.
Did you guys know?
Guys, I'm very open about my PL.
I was Rena.
That's not Shibi or Shibi.
Shibi's dead.
Kill her.
Let's take a listen.
Is this going to work?
Whoa.
I can't, I hear the media source.
It doesn't let me hear it.
Yeah, I know you guys heard it.
Hold on, I'm just going to play it at the same time from my computer.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, sweet.
Strati just sent me my cover up.
Let's fucking go.
Stimming time.
I've been stimming the intonator.
My whole thing was, this was my, this was my, this was just a default model I bought off at Etsy.
I had another model I got made by Swalcoi, but that never saw the light of day because they got hired to VLR and it will never see the light of day.
But this, this wasn't my design.
I had a different design.
Hold on, let me listen.
I'll play it at the same time so I can hear it.
Or actually I can just mute this and then play it from my headphones.
Why is this in the weirdest fucking place?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nope, nope, nope, self.
Wait, is this why I can't hear it?
Now it doesn't want to play at all.
What the frick?
Why would it play at all?
Bro, I hate, I hate life.
Hey, let music start playing.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, you know what I'll just do?
We'll do this instead.
I don't remember what I said in this.
I know I didn't say anything that was Docsworthy though.
Window capture.
Oh my God, perfect.
Now we can all hear.
Marina, can you stop growling at him?
Let me turn this up.
You guys ready?
Are you guys ready for peak content?
Are you not entertained?
Are you ready?
Can you hear?
Ready to be amazed?
This is what got me into Veeler.
Can I show this?
Hold on, let me ask Strawny.
Can I show my audition video on stream?
Rn.
Oh shit, it does.
All right, cool, I can say it.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I just have to make sure something real quick.
I have to find where the timestamp is that I say something that I got to get rid of.
Don't you say this?
I'm like, oh shit, you're right.
Okay, perfect.
I know the timestamp now.
Okay.
I just won't play you the last 20 seconds.
All right, you ready?
You ready?
You guys ready?
You're getting peak?
Peak?
Yeah, Strawny didn't save me.
Peak stuff.
Yeah, I'm so freaking proud.
Yeah, Pookie, Pookie, do me back then.
She a real one.
Do you guys want to know how I did this, by the way?
So first of all, hi, my name is Sheebie Cottonbums.
We'll probably get make into a clip.
Do you want to know how I got into Veeler?
I just stayed in the basics.
And I kept it short and simple.
My video is actually only three minutes and 30 seconds long.
I didn't even do five minutes because I didn't need five minutes to see how amazing I was.
Honestly, the reason why I was hired was because of my voice acting ability.
Those are the notes that Strawny gave back to me during my interview.
Another thing is, hold on, I'm going to change out of my outfit for this,
because I know this is going to get freaking clipped and people are going to be so confused.
Hold on.
Let me change real quick.
Hey.
Let me change my outfit.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
I'm going to put on some nice little outfit for you there.
My cat is scratching in the litter box.
Here, I'll wear this.
Can I put my arms down? Hello?
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
My neck is kind of popping off. Hold on.
Why am I like this? I need to turn down.
Let me turn down the freaking physics.
Oh, my cookies are ready.
Let me get my cookies. I got a reduction? No, I just made myself bigger, didn't I?
Oh, I did. Hold on.
Siri, stop.
Delicious. Cookies! Do you want some cookies?
Oh, I need to let those cool a little bit.
Let those baby girls cool. Okay.
Hi. Hi.
My name is Shibi Cottonbum.
Are you wondering how I got into viola?
Well, what did I do exactly?
I kept stuff short, sweet, and to the point.
And I demonstrated my voice acting abilities.
That's really it.
And then Shrani just stalked me a lot on my stream so she could see my actual personality
because I am so flat in this, in this video.
I'm just like, hi. Oh, hey there.
Hee-hee, oo-hoo. That's all I really did.
Okay.
And I don't know how I AC auditioned. I still don't know how I got hired.
If you look at this audition and you wonder, oh my God, how did she get in and I didn't?
You know, you're totally entitled to that because I wonder that too.
All right. Let's check it out. Let's check it out, folks.
You ready? Let's go.
Hi. Oh, you're not getting attention to other girls sending in applications, are you?
You're one and only, right?
Yeah, I better be. Or else.
Anyway, hi there. My name is Irina.
I'm a Vtuber that does a wide variety of content from playing Souls Likes.
Who's your worst?
Or retro games.
You're a brat and I want to put you in your place.
Or just yapping away at my chat.
Okay.
Do an RR squat.
RR.
Oh, God. That sounded way looter than it needed to be.
I love entertaining my audience.
I have lots of goals I want to accomplish with a dealer.
It's always been my dream to voice in a game.
And if it's spicy, that gets me even more excited.
I'd also be so thankful to be able to have my own merch create song covers
and make amazing new friends in my gen.
But my biggest goal would be to reach a wider audience
and share my love for voice acting in ASMR like this.
Your body is 70% water.
And daddy's thirsty.
Normally, I'm a cackle priestess, so not only do I love to serve,
but I also love to be worshipped.
I have done only fans in the past,
and I've recently done some not-safe-for-work audios,
and I've commissioned and I've drawn not-safe-for-work art.
So, no, you can't corrupt me more than I already-
Whoops, jump scare!
For me, either.
I think I would be a great fit for be a dealer
because I can do different accents
and I love to embody the voices that I act for.
Whether it be a loli,
the first was a fascination.
Now it's just my lifestyle.
A major brat.
Sometimes being a smug little shit can get you places.
A caring mother.
It's about time I found someone I could love on.
A bo-me-mo-me.
Life can be so restrictive sometimes.
We should cut loose.
For last but not least.
Ropes, poggers, ropes!
Oh, it hurts.
But it hurts so good.
But I do hope you'll consider me for VLR
because it would be my honor to be part of something brand new
in the ENVTuber sphere
and to be able to assist you in your growing into something more
and to make so many viewers stand at attention.
I mean, happy.
That's it!
That's literally it.
I literally hold my breath.
I literally hold on. Let me see.
Hold on.
I think there's just one thing I have to skip over.
I'm done.
Your livestreams will be there in the timeline
and I'm determined to be a part of it.
Thank you so much for watching
and go look at it through the rest of the auditions
and considering bye.
Bye-bye!
Mwah-mwah-mwah-mwah-mwah!
That was it!
That was my audition.
Short, simple, to the point.
I edited this background.
I demonstrated my voice acting ability.
I showed clips that showed my ASMR ability.
I showed a drawing that I made.
That was NSFW.
I showed funny clips of myself.
That was it.
It's really basic.
I'll be honest, though.
I have seen the other girls' auditions.
I will tell you that
Emmys and Mercies are so amazing.
If they ever show you,
you guys are in for a treat.
Sometimes all you have to do is just keep it basic.
Keep it to the point.
Some people take the whole five minutes.
I feel like you have to capture them.
You have to reel them in.
They always tell you in auditions
that you have to catch their attention
in the first five seconds.
I did.
I said,
do you...
Hi, Raina.
Do you...
You're not looking at other girls' applications, are you?
That's what I did.
I did the yandere angle.
Slam, bam, and thank you, ma'am.
Indeed.
Little sis won't show us.
Oh, that's too bad.
Hers is really, really, really good.
I think hers has some personal info.
That's why.
Same with Mercies, if they don't ever show you.
I can't remember, but I think that's why.
Yes.
It has little toys.
That is correct.
Well, yeah.
You probably won't see anybody's.
I'm showing you mine because it's basic and to the point.
And this is such a great, simple example
of how to do a
simple, sweet audition.
You know how I did this, by the way?
I looked at
other people's auditions
in terms of what people asked for.
I did so much research
of people who
got into Corpo's auditions.
But, yeah,
I just was like, hey, I'm funny.
This is my favorite clip, though, my Liza P clip.
Hold on, let's just play this again.
Can we play the Liza P clip?
This is my favorite Liza P clip.
It's great that there's a wide
variety of content
from playing Soul's Likes.
Who's your worst?
That was
the worst.
Bomp.
And, uh, yeah,
I'll 100% play Liza P
because I love Liza P.
It was so good.
I hate
that enemy. I hate that.
I hate that so bad.
But, yeah, then you saw me
how I use lots of different models,
like I use my P and G tube model.
Cause that's that, that right there.
That's what my model actually looks like
is my high priestess thing.
That's what she looked like.
But yeah, that was,
you gotta,
you gotta, you gotta also,
the reason why I was like,
one of my notes also,
I had a lot of vocal fry on when I did my high pitch voice,
my, my cute and funny voices.
And,
right now, what are you doing?
And so I,
after getting that feedback from my interview,
I did work on my voice acting a lot more.
And now I do a lot better, cute and funny voice.
Rena's a child model, she, yeah.
I kind of,
and people at like,
cause they're like, I had someone ask me,
what is it like being Corpo and like giving up your IP?
And I said,
honestly,
Rena was like kind of like my younger self
and she beats my more mature self.
And I, it's two sides of the same coin.
How did you get started on the voice acting?
It literally happened while I was streaming.
I never did it before.
I literally had never done it before.
And so, and then Strani said I was the only person
that read everybody's lines.
And she, I don't know if she said that I was the only person
who read the lines in general,
but she said that,
that's why I caught her attention
is because I read everybody's lines
and I demonstrated my voice acting ability in my range.
And I've even improved upon that since then.
So it's, yeah.
And they held real,
yeah, it's funny because you can hear,
you can hear, you know, the sheebie voice when I do,
it's like, time until we got a,
I don't remember where the line was,
but like, you guys, it's like,
I was, Strani heard my voice and that,
and she's just like, yup, that's it.
That's ropes, that's it.
And I don't know how it was under,
I think, yeah, there's over like 400 people
and I got ropes.
But,
but yeah.
I was like, keep it short, sweet to the point.
Demonstrate your stuff.
Grab with funny clips in the beginning.
Demonstrate, I know like,
Amy demonstrated her singing ability
and I see she demonstrated her DJing ability,
which is very like, very unique.
Show, show how you're different,
show how you stand out.
Honestly, my voice acting,
like I never thought I would get into a corpo
because I never had any like musical ability
and that's usually what corpos look for.
I got lucky because Vila is looking
for voice acting ability and so,
and also like, you know, a good personality to work with.
So I highly recommend if you're interested
in going for gen two,
just work on your voice acting,
work on also like, like you have to understand
when you apply for a company,
they're looking for a certain person,
a certain personality and I damage,
even though I played a cute and funny character,
I still had my moments
because that, that Chibi model could get to like big.
So I would switch between the two a lot actually.
Oh my God, my cats are fighting.
Stop, boomy.
You're alone, bro.
And so like, if you capture their interest in the video,
they'll usually look at your content
that you're currently streaming.
And I think, I think, I remember,
I think Shrani was watching one of my streams
where I was, I think I was playing oblivion
and I was saying, I'm gonna be say so and play oblivion.
So I used my grown up nun model
and I was acting like,
and I was kind of talking in my ropes voice, my Shibi voice
and I think that's why I got it.
And you, like you hear the story that Shrani tells
where she was watching a Zera stream
and all Zera had to say was like three words.
I need gold, I need gold.
I can't even do her voice.
Hi, Reena.
Are you over here because Boomi's bothering you?
See your voice a game goal.
Oh yeah, well, I'm already voicing a game.
A lot of my goals in Vila have already come true.
I'm like, the game's probably gonna come out
either this month or next month.
I don't know how the progress is.
And yeah, it's just like you just have to,
and you also just have to be comfortable
with the content that you'll be making.
But I'm personally very, very excited for Gen Two,
the types of voices and personalities
as I was gonna say, Reena, chill out.
As I was gonna say is a company,
we have pre-made models.
I didn't like get to make Shibi.
I didn't make Shibi though, Strawni.
I'm Strawni's brainchild and the refling's child.
Strawni's going to find someone
that matches the voice for Gen Two.
If we have a cute and funny girl,
she's gonna look for a cute and funny voice.
If we have another sort of like mommy character,
she's gonna look for a more mature voice
and a certain personality.
The thing is like, so try to feed
in two different like voice tropes
to show that you have a variety
so that people can like,
you can garner interest from Strawni.
But yeah.
Yeah, I'm gonna mess with Gen Two, fine.
I get along with anybody, to be honest with you,
like it's hard.
The only thing that like stops people
from getting along with me
is the type of content that I make and that's fine.
I totally respect people for that
or the type of people that I work with
since I see an Emmy, arcane, funny and stuff.
But yeah.
Chances be a lure, we need a monotone straight girl.
The antics of Gen One and Two, maybe, I don't know.
Who knows?
But yeah, no, I look forward to it.
I'm very excited.
Now that I'm not, I never finished reading that.
I never finished reading My Immortal.
But yeah, it's pretty, pretty, pretty basic stuff.
It's not, I didn't go crazy with it.
I didn't try to, you know, I don't know.
Kudere girl, that would be pretty difficult to do Kudere.
I might be a part four.
I realized it's 11.
I started streaming at eight.
Oh my God.
The hell?
How am I still here?
How am I awake right now?
Actually, no, I took a nap, I'm fine.
After the brain rot, Genshin.
What is possessed?
It's possessed.
No problem, no problem.
If there's any, I'm probably gonna see
if I can get that all clipped
and I don't know, people will have to dig through this VOD
to find helpful information.
Was it cute to see you back then?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was, but like, honestly, I'm not any different.
I just use my natural speaking voice as she be.
This is my natural speaking voice.
Whereas when I was reading it, I would talk a little bit
higher and I would talk like this.
Like that was really it.
And you still hear that voice sometimes,
like Rina peeks out when I'm super, super hyper or happy.
Bunspeak is, yeah, exactly.
That's why you're not wrong.
Bunspeak is written up because I put that there
because I know my voice does that naturally.
Like get high pitched when I'm happy.
So that's why I put in Bunspeak.
It's fun seeing how you used to be and how you are.
Meow.
Yeah, yeah, it's cool.
Cause I was about to give an example of like another person
that went from one person to a new,
but I'm not gonna just like casually talk about PL stuff
when they're not in my company.
But like, actually, I could talk about like Emmy,
for example, like Emmy used to be,
cause she's very open about being Loviti and stuff.
She used to be like kind of like a normal spider girl
of average body type.
And now she's cute and funny.
And now like, but they had the same voice,
but it's different body type.
So it's very interesting.
You'd be surprised about like who you can be,
who you can become.
And it's such a really cool experience.
Like having like, Shibi is so me now.
Like she is me.
Like she actually feels more of me than Rena ever did.
So it's really funny how that happened.
Like I thought, I thought I would like be really sad,
not being cute, funny, but like I have,
I can always like do a project where I am cute, funny,
like cute, funny, Shibi,
or I can make a project where I'm this or that or that.
Cause what I love about Vila is that we have creative freedom.
And if I have an idea, I get to tell Strani
and Strani is like, that sounds amazing.
Let's do it.
And it's great, you know?
I did find my place.
It is different.
Cause people find out anyways,
it's just like an open secret who people are.
Again, it kind of ruins,
can ruin the kayfabe for some people.
But then again,
people usually find out who they are anyways.
So does it really a matter in the end?
It's like, everybody knows who the PLs for like,
hololive are.
Like, come on.
Everybody knows the PLs like pixel of, you know,
Kauai of insert other Corpo here,
insert other Corpo there, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Also, I was a literal nobody in my PL.
So it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really affect people.
There are some big names who PLs will never found.
That's true.
That's a good point.
There is someone who I've always been curious
who they were in the past.
But some people have their stuff on lock.
Honestly, I, when I came into Vila,
Shrani was like, oh, you know, when you get like,
when we, when you debut, you can say who you are.
And I was honestly going to keep that on lock.
Like I was never going to say who I was.
But then I decided, you know what?
No, like I'm going to be open about it
because like I want to show people like who you can become
versus who you were before.
Hi, Histees.
Oh no, my allergies.
But, and then again, I don't,
so because the only thing that I don't like,
and I know that like, Amy doesn't like this too
because we're the most open about our PLs,
is like, don't ask to see like our past life stuff
in terms of like, old content
or archives of our old content.
It just doesn't make any sense.
We're no different than where we were before.
It's like who we were before.
It's just our model is different.
So like, I would prefer people not ask that of us
because I have had people ask like,
oh, can you unarchive some of your rena stuff?
And I'm like, I'm sorry, but no, because I'm right here.
Why would you need to look at my past content
when I'm right here?
And you can look at my current content.
And then I don't want people to think
that I'm funneling them to my PL.
Like, no, I'm not leaving VLR ever.
Like, I'm here all as long as it lasts for a thousand years.
Like, I'm not going anywhere.
Why would I, I don't tell you about my PL
so you can go to it.
I tell you about my PL
so you can just get an insight into who I am as a person,
you know?
Do most VTubers archive their PLs?
Yes, they do.
Most of them delete everything.
I deleted everything.
I deleted my entire Twitch channel.
What are my cats doing?
Let me get some micropinkies.
What are you up to?
What are you doing?
Are you on rena?
What are you up to?
Why are you on my dresser?
Is Boomi bothering you still?
She's like, up on my dresser and Boomi's below it,
like, ha, ha, I'm gonna get her.
Why won't you bring yourself?
Old lady, I don't need you falling off my dresser.
Boomi, leave her alone.
It's cookie time.
Boomi, I'm not full blooded.
I'm gonna get a cup for some milk.
He needs some milk.
Boomi.
Fia is still even.
Oh, thank you, Recoma.
What did I, where did I go?
I just, until you're, until you're 90.
That was such a good one.
Yeah, your PL was on Twitch, I remember you saying
something about wanting to do.
Yeah, I wish, I wish there was like channel points
or like animated emotes, yeah.
You know, it's like a relationship.
You need to, you know, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna open up to you and be vulnerable about my past,
you know?
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I'm not gonna talk about anime, I'm gonna finish this.
Don't, don't do this to me.
Oh my God, you guys are so good.
Bye, have a good night.
Don't get too close to, this is already limited.
I'm not even gonna bother appealing this.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna.
Night, night.
Oh, shit slapped.
Guys, it's, it's lactose-free milk, it's fine.
Not, I'm not, I'm not hurting myself with drinking this milk.
It's lactate milk.
Mm-hmm, guys just hear me eating a cookie
when I put my background music on.
You can hear my, you hear me eat a cookie with jazz.
I'm numb, numb, numb, numb, numb.
That is yo-so.
Do you wanna know the secret to having like good cookies?
Almost like perfectly circular, like,
tall house cookies.
So you wanna roll it in a ball.
It is double.
You wanna roll it in a ball
and then flatten it in your palm.
And then when you put it on the cookie pan
or the sheet or whatever you're using,
you want to press your thumb into the center.
Nope, I'm losing my cookie and my milk, no.
Mm-hmm.
Lost a piece of my cookie, ready to go.
Okay.
How does that work?
Have you never seen thumbprint cookies?
That's an eating cookie dough, delicious.
Oh, there it is.
It's for, well, it's so that it.
It's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well,
it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well,
it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for,
well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for,
well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's
for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well, it's for, well,
Why does it keep doing that? It's something, it's like my, I'm wondering if my, what's it called?
My extension cord cable thing is like just not working. I think it keeps dying. It's not the XLR
cable. It's not the XLR cable. I think it's what powers the GoXLR. Because the GoXLR itself is
shutting off. It's not the XLR cable. That's so weird. I'm going to be quiet for a second.
It'll fix itself in a second.
After restart the app.
There you go. Yeah, no, it's definitely, I'm pretty sure it's the cable, it's the power cable
to the GoXLR that's actually going out. I don't know how, but it's whatever. Because if I bump
my extension cord thing.
Yep, it's definitely the power cable. Okay. So let me, I think I fixed it. I think it got like
kind of pulled out. I think that's what it was. I'm wondering if the cats were playing under
my desk and it was kind of pulled out because I just pushed it in and it kind of gave more than I
thought it would. Let me do this again.
Do you know where the idiot is? That's right. It's in the mirror when you look at it.
Okay. Oh, let's finish this. I'm curious how many people got watching me right now.
128 people are watching me be dumb. That's cute.
It's me. It's you. I'm a vampire, no reflection, impressive.
But don't you know, madam? The bird is the word. Sorry. All right, let's finish this
because we only got like four freaking chapters left.
Yeah, five. Wow, that was a while ago. Okay, I'm walking in.
I woke up into Norse's office on a special goff, wait, I should probably change my outfit.
Hold on. Let me slip into something more comfortable.
Well, this is awkward.
Ignore the floating ring.
No, wait, this isn't the right outfit.
Made a shibbony? Why am I my bazonka hunker? So huge. There you go. Made shibbony?
Can I please put this away?
Where is it? Here it is.
Shibbony? Who's Shibbony? You know what? You're gonna be able to see through my hoodie. I don't care.
Shibbony?
Oh my god. Sorry, I'm laughing at discord messages.
Marcy is a hoot. All right.
It's good air flow. Good air flow.
Um, I woke up into Norse's office on a special goffin coffin.
Harigrid was in the bed opposite of me in a comma because vampire and dra- oh, let me run my tongue over. What?
I had I had the desktop audio turned off because my BGM is playing is doubling up, but like
let me fix that actually. That's let me let me run my tongue along that head. God damn.
Uh, all right, bet. Go for it.
I'm waiting.
Go on, give it a lick.
Malone?
Licks it up. Thank you for the for the donut. Wait, did I get any other ones?
Let me take a peek. I haven't been looking. I never tweeted I was live.
LOL, it's fine. I don't know. The real ones are here. The real the real ones only the real ones be here.
The real ones who actually love me or do they? I don't know.
Okay.
$5 tip from anonymous and they didn't say anything. What's up with that?
Well, thank you. Ain't no ni moose.
Whoa.
Arm is itchy.
The Anani moose. I remember when I first started. Wait, no, should I say this story?
Wait, I have to see if that account still exists.
I remember when I first decided that I was going to be a streamer. I made my name Anani mouse.
But I was with like two O's. So I was like moose. So I was a mouse with moose horns.
Yeah, you're never getting to my shut up.
Shut up.
Shut up. My BGM is so loud and none of you guys said anything.
But I was also looked like I looked like a stickman.
But like, no, it wasn't like a stickman. It was like, you know, it was like,
it was like gray and white blob people that were like on new grounds a lot. I don't know.
I don't really know if that makes any sense. I don't know what they're called.
And I looked like a hentai protagonist because I didn't have a face.
And I remember I was playing the witch's house was my first first thing. Tankman, maybe.
All right, let me focus. Let me focus up. We're focusing up.
Fix my fucking pillow. This pillow sucks.
Oh, me Satan, what happened? Oh, me Satan, what happened? I screamed.
Suddenly, Voldemort came. He looks less mean than usual.
Get the fuck out, you fucking bastard. I yielded.
Thou hath not killed the vampire yet. He said angrily.
Suddenly started to cry tears of blood all selective.
Voldemort. Oh, I'm FG. What's wrong? I asked.
Suddenly, Lucy and Professor Sinister and Sirius came.
Bloody Mary and Vampire were with them. Everyone was holding black boxes.
Voldemort disappeared.
Old MFG. No, but you're alive. Scrim to Vampire. I hugged him in Bloody Mary.
What the fuck happened? I asked them. Sorry, I'm rubbing my eye with a frick itchy.
Oh, my Satan, am I like dead now? I gossiped.
And no, be you're almost shot.
Said Sirius, but the bullet could not kill you since you were from another time.
That's not how that works.
This is Shibani. Hi, I'm Shibani. I'm Shibi's niece.
Should I put a disclaimer of that? Hello, I'm Shibi's niece.
I'm gothic, as you can tell. I'm extremely gothic.
Gothic, if you will.
But fangs anyway, said Lucy and holding Otis arm. I gasped. He had two arms.
Omg, I can't believe Vampire's dad shot you, I gasped.
Well, to be honest, Snap was possessed by Snap back then.
What? Said James.
Yeah, he was a spy. Sirius said sadly, he was really a death dealer.
And he was such a fucking poser.
Said Lucy and he didn't even really know who GC were until I told him.
Well, anyone, anyway, everyone started to give me presents.
Why would they give? She's sick. She almost gets shot and she...
Nothing even happened to her. She didn't even get shot and they're giving her presents.
I was opening a black box with red 666s. There was a DVD.
Oh my god, how old is this?
I haven't even, what's a DVD? What's that?
Of Corpse Bride? Like Corpse, like Marine Cor...
Cor Bride, actually, in it, on it, when I gasped.
Mr. Norris locked up angrily because he hated Goths. What is he doing there?
Has anyone seen Draco? I asked gothically.
No, Draco told me he would be watching Hoes of Wax, Hoes of Wax.
Said Professor Trevlery. He doesn't know that's your better.
Anyway, the Norris said you could get up. Come on.
I got up suicidally.
Lucy and... what? Lucy and Sirius and Professor Sinister left.
Sorry, I had a fart.
I was wearing a black leather night gun. Night gun?
Under that, I had on a sexy black leather bra trimmed with black lace,
a black with a matching thong that's a gothic girl on the butt and sexy fishnet.
You know, I want to cosplay as one of these outfits so bad.
So bad.
Like if somebody can find me a thong that says gothic girl on the butt
and sexy fishnets that kind of hooked on my thong.
If you don't get the idea, massage me, I'll tell you.
So, a garter.
I put on a black fishnet top under a black MCR shirt,
a black leather mini with black lace and congress shoes, not converse congress.
I left the hospital's wings with Bloody Mary, Willow and Vampire.
OMFG!
Let's celebrate!
Let's gas little.
We can go see House of Wax with Drake.
Wait, we can go see House of Wax with Drake.
House of Wax with Draco.
Hey, Gold Vampire.
Let's go listen to GC and cut ourselves.
666 at Hermione.
We opened a common room door sexily, and then I gasped.
Draco was there doing it with Snap?
He was wearing a black shirt with 666 under front and baggy jeans.
You fucking prep.
We all yielded angrily.
Yeah, you betrayed us.
Wait, yeah, you betrayed us.
Shooted Vampire angrily as he took out his black gun.
No, you don't understand.
Screamed Draco sadly as he took his thingy out of snakes.
Wait, are they docking?
No shit, you fucking suck, you preppy bastard.
Said Willow, trying to attack him.
You rock girl.
I ran suicidally to my room.
I sexily took the stake out.
And no bean.
And no bean, no.
Screamed Draco, but it was too late.
I slit my wrist with it.
Suddenly everything went black again.
What?
I'm sorry, I'm looking at all your reactions now.
I don't know what just happened.
I don't know.
Chapter 40.
Wait, this is the same thing.
Chapter 41.
She talks about and the authors know how she knows somebody hacked her.
Oh wait, hold on.
I need, I need to cover Jacob's stupid face.
Let's just scroll down.
When I woke up, I was in a strange room.
I looked around.
I was wearing the same outfits I had
when is performed with X black X tier X.
I looked around confusingly.
It was a nurse office, but it looks different on the.
Well, sorry, I read ahead because I got confused.
On the wall, it was a pink of Marilyn Munson.
Just imagine that he is an 80s Gothic band too.
Okay.
He is more old than panic at the disco or MCR.
There was also a Gothic black Beatles.
She's just like, let me just think of 80s, although Beatles isn't even 80s.
This make them emo Beatles calendar with the picture of the Beatles wearing
eyeliner and black clothes on it.
So 1980.
Can you guess where we are?
We're in the 1980s.
Oh, I'm FG.
I'm back in Tim again.
I screamed loudly.
Suddenly Satan.
This is actually Voldemort for photo reference.
Oh, she had a photo reference too, but I'll never see it.
Voldemort was wearing black leather Jackson black tight jeans, fishnet pants.
He looks so sexy.
I almost had an orgy.
I wish I had that ability.
I hope I wish I could just like look at someone and just be like, wow, they're so
sexy and just hands-free organ.
I'd be pretty sick.
This is some very deep Harry Potter lore.
Oh, yeah.
I'm okay for your information.
Oh, oh, I'm FG.
And no, be are you okay?
He asked gothically.
Yeah, I'm okay for your information.
I snapped sexily.
Oh, I'm G.
Am I dead?
Because I remembered I jumped in front of the bullet from James Gunn.
Also remembered seeing Draco doing it with snap.
I guess that's when I had slipped my wrist and went back in Tim instead of dying.
I know I could go forward in Tim time.
Wow.
I'm so used to saying Tim.
I didn't say time.
I found a time toner or the Tim machine.
No, you're not dead.
Saying reassured suicide.
A lazy smocked a cigarette.
Sexly and smoke came all over his face.
You're a vampire.
So you can't die from a bullet.
Yeah, duh.
Hello.
That's a good point.
What the hell is he in?
It doesn't even matter if it was from another time.
I'm a freaking vampire.
Come on now.
Let's go see how Harry's dad is doing.
How does he know he's...
Okay.
I don't know.
Draco going crazy on Pokemon Snap.
I know that the real reason I didn't die from the ballet
was because I was from the future.
WTF.
James also almost shot Lucius.
I said Indigoli.
I know that James had really been possessed,
but I didn't want him to know how I knew.
Yeah, I know.
But he had a headache.
He was under a lot of stress.
Sorry.
Yeah, I know.
But he had a headache.
He was under a lot of stress.
Satan reasoned evilly.
I guess that's okay.
I said, because James had a really shot Lucian.
Also, I know that Lucian would have had two arms instead of one.
I walked seductively outside with Satan.
Suddenly, I saw a whole sexy go...
I saw a totally sexy, gothic bi guy.
She has the ultimate gaydar.
She just looks at you and she's like,
that's a bisexual man.
He had bletched blonde hair with black streaks up to his ears,
and he was wearing gothic black liner.
A black green day shirt.
It showed Billy Joel with blonde hair since it was the 80s.
Black congress shoes and black pecky pants.
He walked in all...
I need to...
I don't remember.
I never lived in the 80s,
but I feel like it was different from this.
He walked in all sexily, like Gerard Gerardway,
Gerardway, actually, in the Vido for...
I don't three you like I did yesterday.
And you could see a black tear on his face like in that video.
Did he kill someone?
Hey, he said I'll quetzly and gothically.
Who the fuck is that?
I asked Angley cause I did not snow him.
This is Hedwig, said Voldemort.
He used to be an ex black XTX2,
but he had to drop out cause he broke his arm.
That sucks.
What is happening?
I'm just looking at chat.
What are you guys talking about?
I don't know what's happening.
Oh, no, no, no.
Hey, Hedwig.
I said seductively, even though I was not trying to be.
I'm just always seductive.
I can't help it.
Oh, well.
Hi, I know he...
I don't know a voice to give him.
That doesn't really matter.
He's probably not going to talk a lot.
He answered, but then he ran away
because he had hair of a magical creature.
Wait, is he supposed to be Hagrid?
Or do they make the owl a person?
Wait, isn't the owl's name Hedwig or whatever?
Did they make the owl a person?
Did she?
Is she sexualizing the owl?
Isn't the owl a girl?
Isn't the owl in Harry Potter a girl?
I'm so confused.
Not the owl.
Wait, hold on.
Pet female snowy owl.
Is this pet female snowy owl?
Why is the owl a hot guy?
Whatever.
He had the hair of a magical creature.
He was humming.
Welcome to the black parade under his breath.
I know that is not the 80s, but pretend it is.
Okay.
She's like, this is all the music I know.
I don't know any 80s music.
Like as if there wasn't like alternative 80s rock bands.
There was only GC, only Marilyn Manson, only MCR.
Bye, I said all sexily.
Dow was Hedwig.
He used to be my boyfriend, but we broke up,
Satan says sadly, looking at his black nails.
Oh, I'm FG.
I can get you.
Wait, wait.
So you're telling me that Hedwig is a hot emo man
who used to date Voldemort, also known as Satan, and they broke up.
A human defied snowy owl.
You know what?
I'm not going to follow this anymore.
I'm not following that anymore.
That's fine.
LMFG, I can get you back together.
I said fingering something I didn't know was in my pocket.
A black coot is what we aim for CDO iPod
that I could take videos with.
What?
Can you take a video with an iPod?
You guys can't tell how much I'm squinting in confusion.
I don't know when this was made.
I don't remember what iPods do that I could take videos with
because does no anyone else know about them.
They kick ass.
I don't know if I could trust her thinking the same news existed.
iPods don't have cameras.
What about?
Wasn't there like an iPod touch?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I remember my dad had one.
Yeah.
And he like, yeah, that's right.
Now my dad uses Android.
Huh, I have to ask him why.
Okay, you can forget about your class for now, Headwig.
I'm going to show you something great.
I led them to the Great Hall.
Come on.
Come on, you guys.
Lucien, James, Sirius and Snake or All in the Great Hall.
Lucien, hold on.
Sorry, attitude.
Maybe this milk is not helping me.
Although it's supposed to be lactose free milk.
It says lactose free in the bottle.
She be pleased.
She be pleased what?
Please step on me.
Lucien wouldn't talk with James because he had tried to shoot.
Yeah, I'd be pretty pissed.
I wouldn't want to be in the same room with somebody trying to shoot me.
Go fuck yourself, you fucking douche.
He shouted at him.
Draco is never going to be friends with Vampire now.
Oh, wait, this is the 80s.
Aren't these, and they're in, they're going to Hogwarts as students.
Let's say that they're like 18, 17.
Do they know they're going to have those kids or are they babies in the 80s?
I don't know.
Yeah, go fuck, sorry.
Yeah, go fuck yourself, Samarro.
Snake.
Snape agreed, but I knew he was lying because it had been his fault James had almost shot Lucien.
Be quiet, you guys.
I said sexily, my plan was working out great.
Not could make Voldemort good without doing it with him.
Now Vampire's dad would never die.
And okay, Satan and Hedwig, you guys can start making out.
I said, and I started to fill them with the iPod.
You know how I can get people back together?
Wow, that's good.
Something's scottishing because it says Meeplan was working.
It's great.
How could I not say that in this scottish accent?
Anytime.
So you know what, I bet this is what Emmy does.
She takes out her iPod that she took from the past
and she holds it up and starts recording two pin pals and the pin pals just start immediately
making out because that's how that works because we all know how gay the pin pals are.
Then she, then she, then she, she, to that later.
Um.
Cool.
Said serious as Voldemort and Hedwig started to make out sexily.
Now I'm just picturing Voldemort and the owl making out.
We watched as they started to take each other's clothes off sexily.
Some were a serious snake and Lucy and all watched because they were probably by.
I knew Snape was by.
Oh my fucking God, Voldemort, Voldemort, screamed Hedwig as his Glock touched Voldemort's.
What?
His what?
His, his what?
His Glock?
But suddenly everything stopped as the door opened and came dumbly door misses Mr. Norris.
Chapter 42.
What if he touched Glock, touched, touched Glock's at the range?
My immortal must have inspired Rowling to reveal Dumbledore was gay.
I forgot that that was a thing.
I forgot he was gay.
She's using guns as you.
Yeah, you can think of it like that.
What are you?
I think so.
I think they did say that.
Somebody, Jamie, look that up.
Look that up.
I sat depressively in Dumbledore's office with Hedwig, Satan, James, Sirius, Snape, and Lucien.
Dumbledore was sitting in front of us cruelly.
He looks more young than he did in the future.
He had taken to iPod away and was now listening to it.
Wait, what does I forget?
What is that actor that plays young Dumbledore?
Oh, it's Jude Law.
Jude Law is pretty cool.
I liked him in Gadica.
That's pretty cool.
Jude Law is pretty cool.
Wait, this guy, please.
I'm sorry, I'm watching.
I just watched The Last Kingdom and this guy's in it.
I don't know.
He also plays like an even younger Dumbledore.
That's interesting.
All right.
Last Kingdom is good.
I'm almost done with it.
Where was I?
He did into the future.
He had taken to iPod away and was now listening to a shitty Avril Lavigne song.
Is Avril Lavigne not Gothic?
Avrilene was a scene queen.
What are you talking about?
Was I a prep for listening to Avril Lavigne?
Holy crap.
Girlfriend was my shit.
No, she's prep.
What?
Yeah, since 2002, Dumbledore has been gay, apparently.
I guess I'm prep.
Oh no, my life's a lie.
What the hell is this anyway?
He cackled meanly.
I hope he didn't find out that I was from another time.
I think if I was the principal and a master magician,
I think I could tell if somebody was from another time.
Whatever you do, don't blame Ebony, jerk.
Yeah, seriously, she was trying to get a headway back together.
Seriously, I'm just, like, differencing my pitch.
I don't even care anymore.
Serious said, deviantly.
Be quiet, you satanist.
Dumbledore cockled.
If you're lucky, I'll probably send you all to Azkaban.
Akazabans, actually.
That'll teach you to copulate in the Grey Hall.
He changed the song into iPod to an in-sync song.
It's just, like, it's just deadpool dancing in-sync.
Suddenly, I notice something strong about the iPod.
It was surely tronging.
Chonging.
Dumbledore didn't notice.
Wait, why is there an iPod in the 80s?
What?
Wait a second.
Why is Dumbledore Southern?
Because I made him a cowboy.
He's Southern.
You're questioning this now?
I don't know, it just popped into my head.
I forgot when iPods came out.
Guys, I have a terrible sense of time and direction.
I don't even know where I am, who I am anymore.
You fucking poser.
I muttoned.
But you never heard of GC?
James said.
No, I knew what the iPod was charging into.
Morty McFly's Tim Machine.
Shut up, jumps.
Draco's dad shouted.
Yeah, shut up.
Snake said properly.
No, you shut up.
Dumbledore said Tom.
Who the fuck is Tom?
I've had enough of you sighting this in Moscow.
Shouted Dumbledore spireously.
Suddenly I grabbed the iPod from him.
Everyone jump in before it's too late.
I jumped into it.
Wait, what?
But only one other person jumped in.
It was Satan.
Why would I?
Why would I want to take these people to the future?
That's messing with the timeline, bros.
Does she know anything about timelines?
She's going to mess up the timeline.
The TVA is going to come after her.
You don't do it.
Wait, no.
You, you don't her heads.
You don't her heads.
Screamed Dumbledore wisely as he went.
I looked around.
I was in the Slytherin common room of Satan.
I was wearing my outfit changed.
I was wearing a plaid plaid plaid.
Many skirt with hot pink fishnets, a sexy black MCR corset,
and black stiletto boots with pink pentagrams on them.
My earrings were black Satanist sins,
and my raven hair was all around me to my mid-black.
My mid-black.
Feel like I had a wig of Voldemort really didn't even touch this.
Tom Riddle?
Yeah, that's what I'm like.
Is that Tom Riddle?
I don't know.
Is it, who's Tom?
I don't, I never watched the Harry Potter,
I'm only seeing the first Harry Potter movie.
And I remember they were playing
one of the Harry Potter movies at school,
and there was a dementor in it.
And I was crying really hard,
and it gave me nightmares.
And my mom called the school,
and she said,
stop showing demonic things to children.
And then now, and then every time they watched
a Harry Potter movie,
I had to get removed from this class.
I wasn't allowed to watch it.
I watched Harry Potter in secret, the first one.
Dementors were terrible.
Wait, what does a dementor look like again?
That's actually freaky, bro.
Like, what?
That's terrible.
Why would they show this in a kids movie?
What even are dementors?
I don't even know if they just suck your soul out,
you body.
Are they, are they velar?
Dementor for velar, when?
Oh my god.
A girl in gen two that's like,
a ghost, like,
dementor looking thing,
like Aldrich being,
and she just sucks the soul out.
Dementors suck your emotions?
Or they suck your soul?
I don't know.
Be sucky.
Be sucky, fucky.
Hey, cool.
Where is Diz?
He asked an emo voice.
This is the future.
Dumbledore's iPod that he tried to take away for me
was really also a Tim machine.
I told him.
Cool, what's an eyepatch?
He whimpered.
He whimpered?
Cool, what's an eyepatch?
I don't know, what does a whimper sound like?
It's something used to listen to music.
I yacked me.
I'm not, I don't yap, I yak.
Oh my fucking god, cool.
Wait, what's the full letter word for dirt?
He asked in a sexy voice.
I guess sand?
I laid confusedly.
Yeah, I was just trying to make sure you were still the same person.
Guys, if I don't, if I'm not acting like myself,
and you think I've been, my body has been swapped out,
just ask me what's another for letter word for dirt.
And if I say sand, it's me.
That's our code word, okay?
If I get body snatched and the person doesn't answer properly,
then you know.
That's our code word.
If I ever get swapped out with like a skinwalker,
suddenly some of my friends walked in.
Oh my, my god, you're fucking alive.
So Ginny wearing a black leather jacket,
black baggy pants, and gothic black from first to last shirt.
But I explained to her why I was alive.
Konichiwa, bitch, said Willow.
She was wearing a black corset showing off her boobs
with lace all around it and red stripes on it.
With it, she was wearing a black leather mini skirt.
Sorry, I don't know why.
Suddenly a dyslexia reading mini skirt.
Big black boots, white foundation, black eyeliner,
red shadow, red eyeshadow, and black lipstick.
It's like when something's written normally,
I have to reread it because my mind is thinking something's wrong,
but it's because it's written normally
and I'm used to not seeing things written normally.
Cook purse, we need proof of this.
Hey motherfucker, said Diabolo with his red hair.
This is Ron Weasley, by the way.
His name is Diabolo.
His parents were actually vampires.
He was kidnapped as a child.
And I'm not joking, that's the lore in the fan fiction.
He was wearing a black panic at the disco.
T-shirt in black baggy pants.
Hey, who's that, Ebony?
Bloody Mary questioned as she walked in wearing a black T-shirt
with a red pentagram on it with lace at the bottom,
red leather pants with black lace and black stollettos.
Oh, it's Satan.
I told her and she nodded knowing the truth.
She just knows.
Why would you, why would you know?
How would you know that?
Suddenly, Satan started to cry.
Are you okay, Satan?
We asked concerningly.
Oh my fucking god, you're from the future.
What if you don't like me anymore?
Cause we're, we're from different times.
He asked.
No, I still like you.
I still say, I said sexily to him,
even though I have a boyfriend and I'm just using him,
apparently.
Like what the fuck?
This is honestly, she's kind of fucked up.
She's kind of, she's kind of fucked.
Okay.
He said reassuredly.
I let him listen to teenagers.
Teenagers scare the living shit out of me.
And I can't care less as long as I live.
So talk in your clothes and strike a violent pose.
Maybe they'll leave you alone, but not me.
All right.
On my iPod, while I was about to go outside
to find out some things,
I gave Diabolo a signal to keep Satan occupied.
Satan fell asleep.
I took the iPod.
I was about to walk outside.
Professor Sinister ran in.
She was wearing a Gothic black mini dress
with depressing blacks, depressing.
Okay.
Black stripes and the white and black stripped tights
in red converse shoes.
Oh, I'm, I need to buy myself some red converse shoes.
I missed having a pair of those.
She was wearing lots of back black illiter.
I got to let me remember the AMV of the song.
Dark times.
You mean great times.
Bring us back.
Oh, my fucking, wait, who's talking?
Oh my fucking God.
Where is Draco?
How did Snap get back in here?
I taught us he was in Azerbaijan.
Bahian.
Hian with the J.
I asked sadly, what's up, gold mask?
Pet gold mask.
Um, oh, what was that?
He just like lightly pet my hand with his paw.
Hi.
Do you just want love now?
Are you asking me to go to bed?
Oh, you just want pets?
Oh, he's placing his paws on my chair arm
and he's just looking for pets.
Hi.
Hello.
Pet the puppy.
Hello, puppy.
Hello, gold mask.
What are you sniffing for?
You're like sniffing.
It's probably the cup of milk I had.
I have brain rather.
Yeah, but I have three dogs.
Ranala, Melania and gold mask.
Ebony, I was so...
What?
Who's talking?
Ebony, I was so worried about you,
but I know you can't fucking die because you're a vampire.
Snap came back because that girl Brittany freed him.
I never liked her.
She was a bad student.
Trouble reset reassuredly.
That bitch...
Wait, Brittany Spears went and freed Snape from Azerbaijan?
Oh my God.
Bumi, why are you just standing?
He's just standing on his hind legs like a scary possessed cat.
I mean, dog.
Yeah, why don't you lay in the bed then, big man?
Why don't you lay down?
Good boy.
Oh, good boy.
Yeah, I gotta call you.
Oh, I should call you boy in the bed.
Do your dogs get along with your cats?
Oh, yeah, amazingly.
I have three dogs.
Like guys, I only have three dogs.
I don't know what you're talking.
I don't have cats.
The dogs me out.
Yeah, they're all I'm filing will.
Okay, wait.
That bitch.
Did she also free Hargrid in Lupin?
I shouted angrily.
I hated Brittany because she was the fucking prep.
Yes, they're on the loose at the school.
Dumbledore's back.
Connolly is on his way to help everyone.
Tell everyone you see to lock themselves inside of their common room.
Conman room.
Trouble reset wordly.
Okay, but where's Draco?
How come he was doing it with Snape?
I don't know why, but he almost tried to commit suicide.
After he saw it, you almost kill yourself in Minecraft, she said.
OMG, that's terrible, I guess.
Satan was still asleep.
So wait, why?
Wait, I tried to sweet say it all.
And so he decides to hook up with Snape.
And then when I find them, he tries to sweet say it all himself.
I don't understand.
I said he was still asleep, so he couldn't tell what was going on.
Then I said, listen, everyone, I have something impotent to do.
In hour, everyone stay.
With that, I ran out.
Good luck, Tara!
Everyone cried.
Who the fuck is Tara?
I ran sexily down the stairs into the great hall.
Well, the portraits around me looked at me scaredly.
There was hardly anyone else in the stairs, and then Tara was an
epsomosphere of horror.
On the way, I saw Brittany laughing on the stairs.
She was wearing a slutty pink shirt with flowers on it.
Blue jeans skirt, Armoury Cromby, and pink stilettos.
She looked just like a pentagram.
I was fucking preps, Hilary Duff, and Lindsay Lohan.
I remember a pentagram instead of a pent-
instead of a cross between, it's a pentagram between, because I'm gothic.
All right.
Terbithia?
Oh my god.
You fucking bitch.
I shouted angrily.
No, you are totally a bitch.
No, Voldemort will like totally kill you.
She laughed.
Crucious!
I shouted selectively, pontificating my black wand, and she started screaming
because she was being tortured, and I laughed so distantly.
No, help me please.
I'm a slave for you.
I put up my middle finger at her in her hand.
I saw the video camera, Snape and Lumpin, how he used to take the video of me.
I put the tape of Voldemort doing it with Hedwig onto it.
Then I just continued around the stairs with the camera.
When I had reached the Grey Hall, I saw Vampire Potter.
OMG, Vampira!
I yielded.
We hugged each other.
He each utter happily.
He lucked at me with his gothic red eyes and spiky black hair.
Around them were black eyeliner and eye shadow.
A new product from Apple.
His, he was wearing a black leather Jackson leather pants,
a panic at the disco concert shirt, and his black congress shoes.
He looked more like Joel from Good Charlotte than ever.
Did you hear their song, The River It Rocks?
I was so worried you died, you moaned vampire.
I know, but I'm a vampire lol.
When I woke up, I was back in 1980.
So anyway, I brought Voldemort from when he was young with me.
Where's Draco?
I asked seriously.
Draco, you mean that fucking poser who betrayed you?
Vampir snarkled with anger and a sexy voice.
I know, but we have to find him.
I said smarty.
I'll do it then.
Wake me up.
Sorry to do the voice, I have to go wake me up.
I'll do it then.
Harry said angstily.
Okay, I agreed.
Suddenly all the lights in the room went out.
And then the dork mark appeared.
Oh my fucking sight!
Harry shouted.
I think Voldemort has arrived.
I said angstily.
He's standing right behind me, isn't he?
Fuck, I have to find Draco.
I guess we should separate.
Okay.
Vampir probably said disapariting.
Sadly, I ran into the Great Hall.
Chapter 43.
Oh my gosh, this is a short chapter and then it's the end guys.
Can't wake up.
Careful the eyeshadow doesn't catch fire and burn your eyes out.
In fact, that's my focus line.
Wake me up.
Wake me up inside.
Can't wake up.
Save me.
That's the way I do my goofy voice.
I walked sexily into the Great Hall.
It was empty except for one person.
Draco was there.
He sat there in deadly bloom in his black 6-6 t-shirt
in his baggy black pants.
He had slit his wrist.
1-1-1.
I felt mad at him for having sex with Snap,
but I felt sorry for him.
He looked just like Gerard Way with his red eyes
and his pale white face.
Draco, are you okay?
I asked.
Oh, I'm not okay.
He screamed depressedly.
I thought that MCR song and I got even more depressed
because that song always makes me cry.
I gave him a pot cigarette and he started to smoke.
What's a pot cigarette?
Oh, Draco, why did you do it with that faster Snape?
I asked tearedly.
Oh, Draco began to say,
but suddenly Lumpin and Mr. Norris appeared into the room.
They didn't see us.
I'm so glad we me and Snape were free, said Lumpin.
Damn, this wood job would be great
if it wasn't for the fucking students.
Mr. Norris agreed.
Pop a delum!
I yielded angrily, pointing my wand at them.
No, Lumpin shouted as chains came on him.
Mr. Norris ran away.
He fucking perv.
I said laughing with depths of evil and depressiveness in my voice.
Now you have to tell us where Voldemort is or I'm going to torture you.
I don't know where he is, said Lumpin.
Suddenly, Satan and Vampire ran into the room.
Vampire didn't know who Satan was really.
Oh, my Satan, we were worried about you guys.
Vampire said, I look sexily at Draco.
It's his gothic red eyes with contacts.
Black t-shirt that says, we already discussed what he was wearing earlier.
Why do we got to do this again?
It said 666 on it and pale skin like Drardway.
Vampire with his sexy black hair and red eyes, just like Frank Aero and Satan,
who looked like just like Brandon Urie then.
I selectively.
Took the, it's funny because I just don't think Brandon Urie is attractive at all.
I selectively took the caramel for my caramel.
And then I began Frenching Draco's sexily.
Looping ass.
Draco began to take off all his clothes and I could see his white sex pack.
Then Vampire took his own clothes off too.
Oh, my God, we all began making out together sexily.
I took off my black leather bra, my black lace thong and the rest of my clothes.
Everyone took their glocks out.
Except for me.
I'm a girl, LOL.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, me, Satan, Draco.
I screamed as he put his hardness in my thingy.
Then he did the same thing to Harry.
I began making out.
Would you just have a foursome with Satan?
And he joined in.
Oh, that's one, one, one.
Miles cried Vampire.
Oh, Vampire, Vampire.
I screamed, screamed.
Oh, Satan.
Oh, Satan yelled Harry.
No, yeah, in pleasure.
Lupin watched in shock.
We took turns doing torture curses on him because we're all sadists.
Wait, so we're all just like screwing each other and then we're just torturing Lupin at that, you know?
You know, if I put it in the frame of like, all right, what if I was like
with harem and then we were just like torturing someone, you know, I could see it.
I could, you know, I can get off on that.
Um, suddenly a big black car that said 666 on the license plate flew straight through the windows
and Snap was in it.
Last chapter, guys.
Last chapter.
Ignore, ignore Janice.
That's my car.
Shouted, shooted Draco angrily.
But suddenly it was revealed who was in the car.
It was Snape.
We already talked about that in the last chapter.
I shall free you, Lupin.
But first you must help me kill these idiotic dunderhands.
He said cruelly from the car and flew circumcising above us.
Ebony darkness, dementia, Ravenway must be killed.
Then the dork lord shall never die.
You fucking prep.
You'll Draco.
Then he looked at me sadly.
I forgot to tell you, Ebony.
Snape made me do it with him.
I didn't really have sex with him, but he's a ropist.
A ropist?
No.
We all put on our clothes quickly except Satan.
We were so scarred, but Satan didn't change.
Instead, he changed you a man with green eyes, no nose,
a gray robe and white skin.
He had changed into Voldemort.
I knew who that were all along.
He cackled evilly.
Wait, did he just technically take advantage of us too?
Holy crap.
There's a lot of ropists in here.
He cackled evilly in sarcastically at me.
Now I shall kill thee all.
Thunder came into the room.
No, please don't kill us, pleaded vampire.
Suddenly, Willow, Bloody Mary, Diabolo, Ginny, Dracula, Fred, George,
Hargard, McGonagall, Dumbledore, Sirius, and Lucen all ran in.
What is the meaning of this?
Dumbledore asked all angrily, and Voldemort looked away because Dumbledore is the only
wizard he is scared of.
He did his spell, and suddenly his broomstick came to him sexily.
Voldemort flew above the roof evilly on his broomstick.
Oh my God, Slugborn Gosped.
Get it, because I'm Gothic.
The Dark Lord shall kill all of you, and you must submit to him.
Snap ejaculated menacingly.
You fucking preppy fucks.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Serious.
Shout it angrily.
I know a four letter word for dirt.
Crucifix.
Scream hey, when this box from his own wallet.
Only hit Draco's car.
It fell down.
Snap quickly crawled out of it and picked up the city-o camera.
Oh my fucking god.
I cried because the video of me in the bathroom, the video of me dong with Draco,
and the video of Satan dong with Jim Blank.
If you kill me, then these videos will be shown to everyone in the school.
And then you can just be like that Gothic girl, Paris Hilton.
What?
He laughed immediately.
No, I screamed.
FYI, I have a picture of you doing it with Lupin.
What is she talking about?
Lupin slurped as he sat in chains.
I saw she's gonna show everyone and depict her.
Harry shouted angrily.
Shut up, lumpkin roared.
Foolish ink neuramuses.
Yielded Voldemort from his broomstick.
Thou shall all die soon and die as in tie dye.
We're making tie dye shirts.
Think again, you fucking muggle pose.
Wait, hold on.
Think again, you fucking muggle poser.
Harry yelled, and then he and Diabolo and Navel both took out black guns.
But Voldemort took out his own one.
You guys are in a Latin standoff.
I shouted desperately.
Echo, Neville's wand.
Sorry.
I can't.
Wait a minute.
I thought that was all right.
Echo, Neville's wand.
Cried Voldemort, and suddenly Neville's wind was in his hands.
Now I shall kill thee and all, and every ebony you will die.
Save us, ebony!
Dumbledark cried.
I cried sexily.
I just wanted to go to the common room and slit my wrists with my friends
while we watched Shark Attack 3 and Saw 2 and do with Draco.
But I knew I had to do something more important.
Abra!
Cut Abra!
And that's it.
That is the end of my immortal.
That's how it ends.
We never know what happens.
It just ends like that.
There's no other chapters.
Did you enjoy?
And the whole playing clapped when it ended.
That's the end.
She never finished it.
She never finished it, guys.
Now I can write the ending.
It's up to you now.
You are the author of your own story.
That was one of the stories of all time.
How was that?
How are you guys feeling?
How are you guys doing?
How was it?
It's almost 1 a.m.
Holy crap.
I didn't expect to stream this wrong.
Thankfully, I was a sheebie.
Fia has been sleeping, so she's good.
I'll just wake her up to feed her.
The little baby.
I'm happy.
I'm happy you guys enjoyed.
Let's see.
Let's find someone to raid
because I'm going to end stream here.
She has been sleeping.
What the heck, Toki?
Are you pretty?
This has appeared.
I was trying to get the text to speech on.
Since I wasn't, but my BGM is messing stuff up.
Let me read it out loud.
Thank you, Toki.
What the hell?
We appreciate you so much, madam.
Glad you're able to stream today.
Really do spoil us.
Love you, bunches.
Oh, stop it, stop it.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you, Toki.
You guys, also, I'm not really this manhara.
It was just a bit.
It was just for the bit.
I promise you I'm not crazy.
Please don't leave me.
I promise I'm not crazy.
Please don't.
Please don't leave.
I'll be so lonely.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, that was for the 25.
Thank you.
It's the allergy meds.
And it's the gamer subs.
They got me in my feels.
Well, the hell, you leaving me thing wasn't a joke.
I meant, like, everything else.
Oh, my Satan.
You still love me even if I'm manhara?
You promise?
Do you like me?
You still like me even when I'm manhara?
Do you still like me even when I'm bald?
Do you like me even when I'm bald?
You still love me when I'm bald?
Yeah, okay.
Let me find someone.
I think Stronny's still streaming?
No.
She rated me.
What am I talking about?
Well, sometimes Stronny will rate me
and then do something else and just keep streaming.
So, okay.
I can read.
I can rate Skarl again.
Although, like, it generally doesn't
freaking matter anymore because,
wait, is Mercy still on vacation, isn't she?
Or she's just taking a day to rest.
Because the rate message, like, nobody,
it's so hard to tell if you're being rated.
Because I'll rate Serenity.
She's playing Life Eater.
I don't know what that is, but it looks spooky as hell.
I can't rate Mori-Kaliopee.
I was going to try rating Roar or Panthera,
but it didn't let me.
Because I'm not, you know, they haven't put me
on the white list on accident.
As you guys know, I am part of HoloVeeAlur.
HoloAlur, if you will, is the shorthand.
Or Lur, because we lure people in.
But they'll fix that.
It's just YouTube being silly.
All right, let's rate Serenity.
Um, just say, ooh, Spooky Raid or something.
I don't know.
What is she?
Hold on, I want to see what this game looks like,
to be honest with you.
Um, YouTube's to you.
I forgot that I posted a, I don't know, was that 13K?
I forgot that I posted a, I had a short auto-scheduled.
I have to post it on my main.
Immortal Raid.
Yeah, that works.
All right, guys, I'll see you.
Keep it stinky, you know?
Keeps being smelly.
I'm going to go wake up Fia and try to feed her again.
Then I'm going to go to bed.
I really need to sleep because I have a collab at 10am tomorrow
with Fuwa, because she is in Australian time.
In fact, while I'm still on the computer,
I'm going to buy a said game.
Actually, I can do it from my phone.
That's fine.
All right.
Oh my God, my collar bone is freaking cracked.
Much love, kisses all around.
The sleep is starting to hit me,
because I've been just manic all day.
Vod stays up, bros.
We're not, we're, we're, this is the edgy girl Vod.
I'm going to put, I'm going to change the title
to be like edgy Vod or something or trigger warning.
May have dark themes.
Actually, let me do that right now before I forget.
Details.
Contains dark themes,
but also audition advice, question mark.
It's funny.
Like it's so funny how I switch.
I'm not bipolar.
I'm just, I'm good at my job.
I'm a good entertainer.
I almost played wedding witch instead too.
Hot topic, you're the hot topic contains dank means.
Yeah, I don't even know.
I'm sure people will like do the timestamps
in the comments about like when I'm talking
about my audition and stuff.
I would love to do like an actual, I'm going to do,
maybe I'll do it.
Well, actually not.
I don't really think there's any point of me doing a,
how do audition when it's not even close to audition time?
I'll probably do.
I'm sure scrawny will do it too.
Like a what we're looking for.
Oh, thank you.
Rekuma, what the heck?
Thank you for the five gifted.
You're so sweet.
Thank you.
And don't forget.
Remember I said, I will say thank you again
for that little dollar you threw at me earlier.
You're throwing singles like you at the club.
And it's just like a cheese single.
Um, but I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Bright and early.
If you can't make it, that's okay.
I'm streaming half dead with Fua.
I'm probably going to be half dead
because I'm going to be really tired.
I'm going to have to wake up early
so I can feed Fia because I usually feed Fia around 9 30 10.
So I'll have to do it before that.
But yeah, I hope you guys I'll have like Fua's information
in the in the description and stuff too.
Um, very excited to see you later.
Bye.
I'm E.P.
Stinky.
Take a shower.
Will ya smelly.
Stinky.
Love you.
Maybe.